Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello, guys!
Alright, yes!
Today is Minecraft Story Mode!
I have been looking forward to playing this game for the longest time.
I thought, like, setting this up would be very difficult, because if you guys didn't know...
This game is a Telltale game.
For those who don't know what Telltale games are...
They used to be, like, a really... They used to be, like, a really popular game dev...
Game company?
Game development company?
For various franchises, their most successful one was The Walking Dead.
Which was very surprising, but, like... As in, like, it was very surprising, because in the end...
They went bankrupt, but they had a lot of IPs under them.
So they had Walking Dead, they had Batman, they had... What was it?
The Wolf Among Us?
They had, um...
They were gonna do Game of Thrones at one point as well.
They had Borderlands, they had, uh...
And then they had Minecraft!
There were so many other franchises.
And of a lot of different types of... A lot of different IPs that they made.
And they had, like, a very specific way of doing their games.
And it was all, like, um... It was all basically, like, it was a narrative game where your choices matter.
So each choice you make, uh... Was gonna affect the next episode.
And then they announced they were going bankrupt!
And the entire company closed down!
And I was very shocked at that time, because...
It felt like they kept making really, um...
It kept... It felt like everybody was streaming it.
So, everybody... Not streaming it.
Sorry, I forgot.
It was, like, what?
2012?
Everyone was doing Let's Plays of it!
That was so surprising!
I was like...
How did they go bankrupt?
They literally...
Were gonna make a Game of Thrones, um... Telltale game.
Like, what happened?
Like, it surprised everybody, because everyone was making, like...
Let's Plays of the game, and, uh...
And, like, it seemed like it was really popular.
But apparently, I think they blamed...
They blamed the Let's Players, right?
I don't remember the full story.
But they were like...
Yeah, people love watching other people play it, but they weren't...
They weren't buying the game.
I think that was the argument.
They were like, nobody's buying the game.
Everyone's just watching Let's Players, which was true.
I can see it was... Yeah, I... I was just like...
I guess it's sort of true, because I didn't buy any of the game.
I... I was just like...
I mean, I guess it was sort of true, because, like, I was just watching Let's Plays of all...
Of the Walking Dead, like, Telltale games.
I wasn't playing that.
But I was also young, like...
I didn't have the fucking spending money to buy video games.
I'm playing free to play... I had... All I was doing was playing Gmod, because I only... I couldn't buy, like, a lot of games.
Dr. Cranberry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
After 15 years of making adventure games, this was the game that bankrupted Telltale.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway...
The company's back, though.
I remember, like, someone said they got...
They, like, bought... Like, someone... A company bought them.
So, like, Telltale's technically back, but, like, they haven't been making any...
The games they've been making is not as good as they used to make, because people just...
People don't care about original games.
A lot of people don't really care about original games anymore.
It's more all about, like, using pre-existing IPs.
I think that was... Honestly, like, Telltale's strongest suit was pre-existing IPs, because you can say The Wolf Among Us... I remember a lot of people were saying The Wolf Among Us was a really good Telltale game, but, like, I... More... People talk about...
People talk about The Walking Dead more than The Wolf Among Us.
Like, I... The only thing I know about The Wolf Among Us was the fact that the guy was really hot.
Like...
That's, like, the only thing I knew about that game.
But a lot more people were definitely playing The Walking Dead one instead of The Wolf Among Us.
Was The Wolf Among Us a pre-existing IP?
Oh my god, was it?
Oh my god, it was!
Wait, it was based on...
Oh, it was... Oh, I guess it was based off another IP.
I thought they made up that story.
I was like, what the fuck is this?
Yeah.
But, oh my god, even then, it was not a very well-known IP.
No, the newer... The newest games that they've been making...
What was it?
Okay, I know, like, they're back now.
Because I was thinking... They released the one about space, and I was, like, thinking about trying it out when it was released, but then, like, I was like... I saw the reviews, and I was like, never mind.
I... Okay, let's see.
New Telltale Games.
There is... Oh, The Expanse!
Yeah, The Expanse.
Was that... That one was... Yeah, that's a new IP.
Um, I heard about it.
I saw the reviews, it wasn't, like...
Um, like, I saw the Steam reviews when it first came out, and everyone was just like, eh, it's alright.
That was based on the show.
There's a show?!
Oh my god, am I... What?
What show is this?
That's an 8.5?
Okay, this is the thing about, like, a lot of shows now, especially those on streaming services.
Is this a... Okay, is this a streaming service show?
Okay, I need to make sure... Check.
Yeah, okay, for the Syfy Network.
So, like, this is my issue.
There's so many shows that apparently have really fucking good ratings, but, like, I've never heard of them before.
Like, I've... I've, like...
There's so many shows that are like that, where it's, like, they're like, oh my god, look at these...
Look at, like, the reviews for this show.
It has, like, an... Like, a blank out of 10.
Like, 8 out of 10, 9 out of 10.
And I'm like, what the fuck is this?
I've never heard of this show before.
There's just so many shows.
Uh, so many different shows.
Like, um...
I had several people that were trying to... That were recommending me The Reacher.
I was like, the fuck is The Reacher?
And then I looked it up.
It has an 8 out of 10 on IMDB.
And I was like, I've never heard of this show before.
There's, like, there's just too many at this point.
There's just so many.
Like, I had, like, three people that was like, oh, you should check out The Reacher if you like action.
And I was like, the fuck is that?
I was like, Reacher.
And I'm just like, I've never heard of this before.
I've actually, I've never... And then there's, like, there's apparently, there's a really... There's so many of them are also on Apple TV.
What I've noticed.
What I've noticed is that a lot of them are also on Apple TV.
Because, like, uh, what's it called?
There's one for Maya Rudolph.
That's apparently doing really well.
And then there's what?
What's... Oh my god, what is it?
The new Maya Rudolph.
A lot of them.
Loot, yeah.
How much... What's the reviews for that?
Loot.
That has... Oh, never mind.
It's a 74%.
I thought it was doing really well.
Maybe I'm confusing it with another Apple TV show.
There's apparently a lot of them.
There's a lot of them.
I'm definitely confusing them with a lot of...
There's so many shows I'm confusing them with.
Um, no, I've been watching Severance.
I love Severance.
I don't like Season 2, though.
Season 1 was great.
I loved Season 1.
Season 2, I was like, What the fuck is going on?
Super Bare Hero, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Season 2 of Severance, nothing made sense until...
Nothing still made sense.
When you watch the final episode, things started to make sense.
But nothing still made sense.
They introduced...
I'm not spoiling anything.
But they they introduced a lot of stuff.
Well, but it didn't I don't know what's going on It was I don't know maybe I'm just stupid but like I was so fucking confused in Season two it like a season one loved it season two.
I was just confused.
Like I don't know what the fuck was going on Anyway, so telltale Had like a particular anyway back to talking about telltale they oh my god I like looked up their Wikipedia and I did not apparently they were gonna have stranger things They were gonna make a before,
you know before they went bankrupt because I guess they bought too many IPs cuz they were like We're never gonna die as a game company Everybody loves our games and then they went bankrupt But they were gonna have a stranger things game they're gonna have a game of thrones they were gonna have wait they have a Wait,
what the fuck?
They're gonna have a mr. Robot.
Oh my god.
They had a mr. Robot game on on the phone Yeah, anyway, look at They're just like clearly lots of people are buying our video games Because look at how popular they are when let's players play them and then they forgot that we're just watching those let's players Cuz it's basically the same thing I Appreciate it really they all they did it already.
I don't even remember them doing Game of Thrones.
Oh my god It must be really bad.
I do not remember the episodes at all.
I also never watched Game of Thrones.
I like I've like I've only I watched the first couple of episodes of Game of Thrones and Um, and I just wasn't into it it was just alright for me There was just okay and then like there were so many sex scenes that felt like it was unnecessary
Just like I was like I was just like What's that need it felt like I had there were like in the first couple of episodes I felt like they were like one per episode at least one per episode.
So then I was just like, okay I was just like, all right, look like if it advances the plot I get it, but I was just like it That's just so confused No, no, it's needed for the plot Turkey you don't understand What else were they so I remember like I complained about that to one of my friends and then my friend was like what else were they supposed to do back in the old times This was their hobby to pass the time it makes sense that that's they show that a lot because what else were they gonna do and then Just like and I'm just like yeah,
but like Hey, we could look at what the other kingdoms are doing.
We don't have to show like how they're passing the time I'll stop talking about Game of Thrones Yeah, so they did Jurassic Park when the fuck did they do Jurassic Park 2011 there was law and order.
Oh my god, there was back to the future Okay, I did not realize there were a lot.
Oh my god There were so many duds.
I just I just realized how how they were They actually stretched themselves then they wait.
Yeah, I was like what?
Okay now I know why they went bankrupt guys Now I know There was no way they're making back that money They did a lot of stuff that I wasn't even aware of there was what the fuck was poker night I Like oh Oh, I remember this one.
I remember this is when you play poker against like other IPs cuz they just had too many IPs at that Point I remember that one And then they just kept doing they just kept doing Walking dead because that was their cash cow Can you go think of this super chat?
Thank you.
Dookie now has to play all the games Airport and thinking was super chat.
The expanse is very good sci-fi, but not sure if it's really your thing Also, the last season really fell off when it was canceled Thank you.
I just think nope.
I just think like you're never gonna You're never gonna be satisfied with any finale Cuz like it's so hard to make a good ending for a show Cuz even if you think it's a good ending someone's gonna not like the ending and also it's hard to make endings for shows that are like beloved and stuff cuz you have to like Satisfy his fans,
but you don't want to make it like a hat like a super duper happy ending cuz it's just incredibly cliche I Honestly can't on the top of my head Think of any show right now who's ending that actually liked I I don't I can't I can't even remember any I can't even remember any show that I've watched that actually liked the ending I Never watched Breaking Bad cuz I got too sad.
I was just like I was I tell you okay I always tell you guys this but for those who don't know I've never watched Breaking Bad Because like I usually try to avoid like super heavy Drama shows where like it's just like What's it called what's that word called where it's basically just trauma dumping the show
It's just like I feel like Breaking Bad is like one of those categories where Yeah, I just you know, I just don't want to be sad and throughout the show like throughout the episodes and And so like but I don't want to be sad throughout it Anyway, anyway so I I got really depressed watching the very first episode of Breaking Bad and I watched a little bit of episode 2 and I just couldn't take it I was just like this is just way too sad.
Like I like oh, I like Bojack Horseman.
I wasn't The ending was okay, I would say Bojack Horseman's ending was okay I won't say it was the best ending but it wasn't a bad ending I didn't I what I didn't think I didn't think it was like a super great ending to the show That's an even saddest show,
but they're funny talking animals.
It's like not as real Okay, okay, so this is my reasoning this is my reasoning like they're animated So like it like at least like, you know, when sad things are happening.
I'm like Funny talking horse at least he's a horse, you know But because I'm like, oh man, it's it's it's not actually real because they're just funny talking animals But like when but then I look at Breaking Bad and I'm like, oh this feels way too real like he has cancer Like It could happen to anybody look at him He's just a regular guy and then in Bojack Horseman.
I know like one of the producers in in this show Not the actual producer, but there's a character in the show that gets cancer, but then I'm like, but then like But he's not an animal, but I'm like, he's just animated.
It's not real like his cancer I Like like I disabled the reality I make sure to separate it from reality because it's animated But when it's like IRL like when it's when it's like live-action, I can't separate it.
I'm like, oh my god He actually has cancer
Look that's that's how I like separate.
Um, I like I'm able to separate it between the two
Okay Cancer's fake because he's not real.
He's not he's animated.
So I don't feel I mean I feel sad to the character But I don't feel as sad knowing that Walter White had cancer or has cancer So cuz I'm like, oh my god, he's so real But that's my that's how I separate it, uh, but yeah, I never watched Breaking Bad Because of it cuz I just got way too depressed watching it Anyway another funny story well,
it's not really a story but uh Um So I got reached out by like a sponsor to like the thing to like potential sponsor or something And it's really funny because they like they use CC instead of BCC So CC makes it so that I can see who else they reached out to and then BCC they've used BCC Extension I they get to you know,
they email several people or BBC.
Sorry BBC.
I don't remember And you can you can send it the email to other people and but they won't be able to see who else they said it to so they use CC instead and the thing is I saw Who they reached out to and Sinatra was one of them and it's so funny because When my manager replied back They like deleted all the people that they added.
So it was me.
They emailed this to like four other people.
And Sinatra was like one of the people they emailed it to.
And my manager would reply back.
They deleted the extended thing and just replied back to the developer.
Sinatra as in the FPS player.
Like the Twitch streamer, Sinatra.
Not Frank Sinatra.
There is a Twitch streamer.
His name is Sinatra.
Anyway, so this funny thing is Sinatra's manager, who by the way is actually part of a big talent agency, replied all.
I was like bro.
They replied all and like gave their rates.
So I know how much they get paid for their sponsor.
I was like oh man, that's their...
I was like whoa, that's their rates.
I mean understandable because CCP is a lot.
But I was just like bro, why did you reply all?
I was like bro.
And they gave like...
I'm not gonna say it.
I'm not gonna say his...
I'm not gonna say what his rates are.
But I literally saw like how much he gets paid hourly technically by sponsors.
And I was like damn.
I'm not gonna say it guys.
Not even like if you buy my...
You can't buy this stylus.
I don't want to get in trouble.
I'm just letting it out there that hey, your manager sort of fucked up a little.
And thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you Riverdale.
I never watched the ending of Riverdale.
I stopped after...
I stopped watching Riverdale because I didn't have time.
Because each episode is a fucking hour long.
I swear if I look away from watch...
If I look away for like five seconds if I'm watching Riverdale.
I would miss like 10 different plot points.
So I just never was able to finish it.
Because the last season...
The last season Riverdale I watched was when they got involved when Jughead went to a private school.
Because he got like a scholarship or something.
So Jughead went to a private school.
And then he joined like the writer's club or something.
And then the writer's club was apparently a fucking cult itself.
So and then the most fucked...
I remember talking about this before but it was so fucking stupid.
So the teacher slash head of the writer's club that oversees the writer's club.
The writers, the producers of Riverdale hated that actor.
So they just killed him off.
Like they just made him jump off the window and was like he's dead now.
But like there was no plot value.
They just hated the actor.
So they literally wrote him off because the actor pissed off the producers.
He just dies.
They just like wrote him off and he just dies.
And then they don't touch upon that anymore.
So like the whole plot story regarding the writer's club sort of like...
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Like it just got like brushed off because they're like the teacher's gone now.
Like how do you fix the plot?
You don't.
They just add 10 more plot points in there.
So it makes you forget.
They make you forget about the previous plot point.
And then just add like 10 more new plot points in there because then you'll be focused on that.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Please finish watching Riverdale and then explain it to us.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I thought I was like incredibly interesting.
I was just like, wait, but like what happened to the writer's club plot point?
Like are we just gonna ignore that?
Like is it just gone now?
It felt like there was a lot of build-up to it, but I guess we just ignore it.
Anyway, but yeah, that was that story.
Hey guys, okay.
All right, we're gonna play.
Sorry, sorry, I rambled a lot today.
All right.
Anyway, today, Minecraft story mode.
I have no knowledge about...
We did a lot of yapping today.
But yes, I have no knowledge about this actual game itself except for one very important part.
Which is the most famous part that anyone outside of Minecraft knows about.
So that's like the only thing I know about Minecraft story mode.
But I had several friends DM me.
And were like, oh my god, I'm so excited for you to play Minecraft story mode.
It's such a good game.
And then, okay, not several.
I had one friend.
Sorry, I don't know why I lied about that.
Pretending I have lots of friends.
It was like a, it was a, what's it called?
It was like a, a fight or flight response.
Like natural reaction to pretend I have a lot of friends.
So people don't judge me.
But...
Too, too real.
Anyway, okay.
Anyway, so I had one friend DM me about, DM me about how they were super excited.
And this friend of mine is a lot younger than me.
So I was just like, so I was like, wait a minute.
Well, I wouldn't say a lot younger.
I would say like, they are younger than me.
And then, so they were like, oh my god, I, I love, I love Minecraft story mode.
And I, and then I, and then, and then they were like, like, I would love, I would watch Minecraft story mode all the time.
And also watch XQC.
And then that like, explained enough about like, what they were like when they were like, I was just like, oh, okay.
I was just like, okay, I, I, I sort of understand a little bit about this game now.
Anyway, let's try out Minecraft story mode.
So yes, this game, even when it went bankrupt, when Telltale went bankrupt, um, it got delisted in Minecraft, on the Minecraft store.
And there's no way to, the only way to legally own this game is to buy, um, buy an Xbox that already has it installed or buy like, the disc and stuff.
So like, buy the disc and everything.
And um, and yes, I managed to get this game working.
The game works.
That's all I'll say.
All right, I'm super excited.
Okay, not now.
I don't think those servers are alive anymore.
All right, let's play it.
Okay, so this is gonna be...
Oh wait, isn't that Telltale?
That's him, right?
That's him!
That's that guy in those cutscenes!
That's him, right?
Default man?
Yeah?
Oh yeah, that's me!
That's him!
That's my guy!
All right, the Order of the Stones.
All right, this game series...
Okay, so it's all about the choices I make.
Let me know about the sound, guys.
There's no...
There's no subtitles, I think.
All right, let me boost the volume up a little bit.
Oh, there are?
Okay, I'll...
I'll...
I'll up it a little bit more and then we'll look into the subtitles.
This voice acting is so familiar.
Oh my god, look at him go!
He's so strong!
Jack Blacksleeve will remember that.
He apparently was supposed to voice act the fucking pig in Minecraft.
Look at the super chat.
Uh, actual.
Thank you, thank you.
These four friends together would give so much to gain their rightful place as four heroes.
They don't have a medic.
Who the fuck is gonna heal them?
To fight a mysterious creature known as the Ender Dragon.
But where the fuck is their support?
The Order of the Stone emerged victorious and the dragon was defeated.
Their story complete, they slipped away into the pages of legend.
But when one story ends, another one begins.
Would you rather fight a hundred chicken-sized zombies or ten zombie-sized chickens?
Yeah, just to be clear, you wouldn't have any weapons or armor.
Oh shit, uh, chicken-sized zombies.
I'll take the, uh, the little tiny...
Oh wait, no, they're like so tiny!
A hundred of them.
I forgot it's the chicken jockey!
Oh my god!
They're so strong!
The baby zombies!
I forgot baby zombies are incredibly strong.
I forgot about it.
Chicken jockey.
Oh my god, there's him!
There's Reuben!
Can't wait to fall in love with this character and nothing bad is gonna happen to Reuben.
Reuben's my best friend.
I love Reuben.
I'm already so attached, guys.
Yeah, embrace it.
We're never gonna change.
Yeah, that's right, Olivia.
You're a loser!
You know what he sounds like?
He sounds like Patton Oswalt.
What's his name?
Patton Oswalt?
Is that his actor's name?
Wait, but the sun's out.
Is that Patton?
That's Patton Oswalt?
I think that's Patton Oswalt, the voice act!
In Minecraft?
I just don't say anything.
Oh my god, Brad and Tui himself!
Wait, can I...
Okay, audio-visual.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, let's get medium because we need that.
All right.
There we go.
Oh my god, wait.
Are we actual losers?
Looks awesome.
Wait.
Yes.
Oh my god, we're nerds!
Okay.
What do I do?
Oh my god, I'm playing the game!
Oh!
Okay, what do I...
What do I...
What do I grab?
What's wrong with that?
I'll see you guys at the lockers.
Wait, they're still alive?
How many years has it been?
Yeah, that's right, loser.
You definitely will.
Why the fuck would I need shears and some sheep?
Get the pumpkin!
Shake the pumpkin!
And when we do, people will look at us and say...
Hey, there goes Jesse and Ruben.
Winners of the Endercon building competition.
That's me!
Really should change the name.
Okay.
Oh, bring up a really small amount?
Okay, let me adjust the audio real fast.
Um, maybe I'll turn the music down a little bit too.
I put it large because I can't see very...
Okay, let's see.
I'm also like lounging back because I know I don't have to actually play the game.
Oh man, I love Telltale Games.
I love Telltale Games.
I'm not...
This is me playing.
Okay,
nice.
All right.
We're good to go?
Okay.
Bye.
Come on, Ruben.
Pigs don't take fall damage, right?
Just chuck him down.
Okay.
Oh!
Spot!
Gabriel the Warrior?
How many diamonds did they pay him?
I'd love to meet Gabriel.
I'm his number one fan.
Totally.
He's awesome.
It'd be amazing to meet him.
Of course.
Didn't end well.
Is that how Ruben dies?
Gabriel Keynote sold out.
Wait, they already met?
They already sold out?
What's wrong with that?
Yeah!
Anything can happen.
Then why have we lost nine of these in a row?
You can't...
No, you can't look at this as...
Look, a thousand people signed up.
It's not my fault.
Maybe no one else will show up.
Now you're being realistic.
Wait a minute.
We're thinking about this all wrong.
The point of the building competition isn't just to build something.
We have to do something to get noticed by the judges.
Okay, then.
So how do we do this?
The PP blocks.
We don't just build something functional.
We build something fun.
The PP towers.
After we finish the fireworks machine like we planned.
Surely the judges will notice that.
And we build something cool on top of it.
We might be on to something.
The PP tower and then we put a white wall block.
That's what the shears are for!
That's what they're for!
I'm so sorry.
They both have their moments.
Both pretty scary.
Then again, you scared the crap out of us.
What else will we do with the shears?
Wait, let's build a creeper.
Oh yeah, let's build a creeper!
Yeah, what's wrong with a creeper?
Oh my God, you're right!
The creeper is...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, El.
Derek, no.
That's the same thing.
Forget it.
Team on three.
One, two, three.
Team!
I can't believe they got Patton Oswalt to voice act.
No wonder Telltale went bankrupt.
Like, how many...
Wait, oh shit.
Oh shit.
I gotta...
Wait, what happens if I fail this though?
Oh, sorry, Reuben.
Wait, how do I...
I can't!
I can't do push-ups!
Look at me go!
Getting that sand!
Oh my God, I'm doing it!
I'm getting better!
Oh, I pressed W!
Go, Reuben!
Look at me go!
Let's go!
Also, I brightened it up a little bit.
Oh my God, I'm gonna beat up some plants.
The hardest structure in this game.
Like, how?
How?
No exercise for me.
Oh my God.
The creeper has no white...
White wool.
It's fine.
Oh, I'm so fucking strong.
Oh, is it arrow keys?
Okay, that actually makes sense.
Let's go, team!
Let's go!
Okay, but they do have a cooler pet, guys.
Hey, I'm a really cool pig, okay?
Bet they won't build anything cooler than me.
We've done this like...
We've done this for like nine times.
So, can we just reuse our names?
We're the Order of the Pigs.
It's so fucking cool.
We're so cool.
Look,
it might not...
It might not be as cool as the Ocelot, but it's still pretty fucking cool.
How do I use my inventory item?
Okay, I'm booth five, right?
Uh, is there anything in the chest?
Hello?
Look, I already said we're losers, so we might as well, like, commit to it.
It's all about the character development.
We're staying in character.
Wait, there's not even that many people here.
How did I lose six times in a row?
Oh my god, this is like...
These camera...
Wait, we're booth four, right?
Okay, no, they're booth four.
We're booth five.
Okay, give me a sec, guys.
I'm here for a character development.
I'll be back soon, guys.
I'm here to look at the competition.
How did I lose nine times in a row?
There's five teams!
Did we never improve?
So, Takeda, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Still cooler than the order of the dog dorks.
Getting lost in the nether, hunting the Ender Dragon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, clearly, someone in our team has to be replaced.
There's no way we lost nine times in a row when there's five teams.
Wait, there's no way!
They went into creative mode!
How the fuck?
Wait!
Our design is so much cooler.
Okay, maybe I need to be replaced.
Their difficulty score is going to be higher than our total score.
How the fuck?
I didn't kill a winner!
Fireworks.
We should probably stop staring.
There's no way!
Look at their gear!
Look, it's the order of the losers again.
Good one, Gil.
We're just looking.
There'll be plenty of time for you all to look at it after it wins and gets shown at Endercon.
You're being unpleasant.
Maybe not all of you.
Endercon doesn't allow outside food or drink.
What?!
He's my pet!
Reuben is not food!
Reuben is not food.
Could have fooled me.
He looks delicious.
What the fuck?
That sounded like a weird compliment.
You'll have to eat me first.
Let's hope it doesn't come to that.
Stop wasting your time, Aiden.
We've got work to do.
How the fuck did he get a beacon?
You're lucky I'm busy.
Apparently, there's like Minecraft voice actors in here.
How's the build going?
Only time will tell, but we're optimistic.
Hey, Petra.
I forgot to thank you for that nether star.
Nether star?
How can I help these tools?
For the right price, I'll help anyone.
If you need anything, you know where to find me.
Do you take IOUs?
None of us know- Okay, let's fix the audio one last time.
All right, let's see.
Uh, what was it?
Okay, turn down music by one more and then...
There we go.
And then we raise it up one last time.
How the fuck?
No wonder we're losing all the time.
They got like a fucking...
They got everything.
All right.
Apply.
All right, let me know if it's better.
Sound guy.
...to find you.
Exactly.
No hard feelings, guys.
If you're cool with Petra, you're cool with us.
Is it cuz- So why don't we just forget about all this?
And, you know, make this about how cool our builds are.
No, we're gonna fucking crush you.
I don't care.
I don't know if you know this, but we're pretty good.
Oh, wait.
I get it.
It's like a joke, right?
This is war now!
No, I'm serious.
We're gonna destroy you.
You know, you're really funny.
That's awesome.
Hey, good luck.
That's right.
This is it.
The 10th time.
Like they say, 10 times the...
I don't know.
10 times the way?
Gabriel!
No!
Okay, handshakes are pretty cringe, though.
The warrior...
Wait, I want to know what the redstone rap is.
Rap for me, please, Patton Oswalt.
Rap for me.
I was promised a rap.
What is this?
That was it.
They literally...
The whole premise is a rap.
They didn't even say anything.
Am I...
Am I building?
Oh, shit.
Okay, I actually want to win, though.
No, we're gonna fucking win.
I'm locking in, guys.
There's no way I could build this any faster, like...
Oh my...
I'm like using my wooden keyboard and everything, too.
Oh, everybody's so slow.
We're so fucking fast.
Did I do it?
I just...
Is that it?
I just built it like that?
Wait, it's 2D.
Oh, man.
That looks so cool.
We'll win this for sure.
The Creeper was definitely the right way to go.
Why is it 2D?
Yeah, I didn't even cover it.
This is...
Guys, people are looking at us.
This is actually sad.
Good build, man.
That's it?
No way.
It's just a bunch of died wolves.
Whoops.
Oh!
Ruben!
Oh, no!
Ruben's on fire!
Ruben, no!
Come back!
The lava's getting closer.
It'll ruin the build.
Ruben's going to get lost.
Quick!
Anyone have a bucket?
We've got to do something.
But our build is...
Save the machine!
The machine is more important!
We've got to cover Jesse.
Be careful.
Save it!
It's more important!
We don't care about Ruben for now!
I'm just fucking...
It's saved.
We did it.
But it took three seconds!
They could have come with me!
Ruben, where are you?
It took them three seconds!
Look, we lost nine times in a row, we have...
We lost nine times in a row, guys.
We can find Ruben later.
That was it!
They placed five bugs!
They could have come over!
Okay, well, obviously, those are Ruben's footprints, right?
Ruben!
Where are you, buddy?
God damn it!
Ruben, I don't want to be out here in the dark!
Come on, Ruben!
Alright.
These definitely belong to a pig.
Hmm, there's no way Ruben made these on his own.
Wait, that's not Ruben's footprints?
Doesn't he have hooves?
Okay, let's grab a carrot, though.
Let's pick that out.
Ruben loves carrots.
Ruben!
One of you has to be Ruben, right?
Did you take your clothes off, Ruben?
Wait, I can...
Ruben!
Are you Ruben?
They all look the same!
How do I know which one's Ruben?
Ruben, are you behind a tree?
Oh, he was not behind the tree.
Can I use this?
How do I use my items?
Oh, chicken!
Ruben, I have carrots, Ruben!
Jason?
Jason!
Okay, but can I burn trees?
Oh, smoldering costume?
What?
What is this?
Oh!
That's like...
See, I knew it!
He's naked!
Jason!
Hello?
Ruben, are you in here?
There's a torch in here.
Someone's...
Oh, it's that woman!
It's that lady that farms stuff.
Ruben!
It's okay, I have a wooden sword.
Wait, how do I use my items?
Is there a way to use it?
I don't know how to use it, so I guess I'll die.
Ruben?
Clearly, it's not a creeper, right?
Or a zombie?
Ruben!
Ruben, there you are!
Oh, you have mu- you have big eyebrows!
Okay, now I know how you look different from the other piggies.
You're in big trouble.
That's right, Ruben!
You better remember that!
Tough love!
I got raised up by tough love and I turned out great!
He could have stopped, dropped, and rolled!
I think we're good.
Oh, shit!
I think we made it!
Oh!
Oh, shit!
There's no way I would have died.
Wait, what happened if I would die?
What happens?
That's right!
Hit me.
Can I actually die?
Well, I'm curious.
Oh!
What happens?
That's it?
Oh, I died.
I'm just curious.
Did I just turn into the smoke?
Alright, don't worry.
I got this.
Get back!
Be gone, zombie!
Oh!
Oh, shit!
Look at that quick time event!
God, I'm such a gamer.
Okay.
That's right, Reuben!
Are you watching, Reuben?
Reuben, are you watching?
Jesus!
Okay, okay, okay, guys!
How close are you?
Oh, shit!
What is the hitbox?
Stupid wooden sword!
What?
Reuben, stop watching!
I know it's bad.
I'll think of something.
Okay, Reuben.
Maybe I shouldn't.
Don't worry!
We'll die together, Reuben.
Too many of them, buddy!
I'll leave that spot no matter what.
Do you hear me?
Don't worry, Reuben.
If we're gonna die, I want us to die together like the Egyptians.
Get away from him!
Oh no, he got you!
It's okay, Reuben!
I'll just feed you some carrots, right?
You'll be fine!
So much for protecting!
Get off me!
Don't worry.
I got this.
Get out of here!
It's okay, I'll give myself a black eye too.
He's so little mad.
Where did Reuben go?
Come on, let's get out of the open.
Reuben, are you okay?
It wasn't my fault, guys.
I was being a really good owner.
I want to show you something.
He's gonna turn into spider pig!
Not that this isn't a really cool dimly lit tunnel, but...
How far away is this thing you want to show me?
Careful, Jesse.
You don't want to get a reputation as a wimp.
This isn't my first time in a cave, Petra.
Yeah, but have you ever seen a wither skull?
Fresh from the nether.
You're the first person I've showed it to.
You went to the nether?
You better appreciate this.
You risked your life for that dusty old skull?
No, I risked my life for the thing I'm gonna exchange for that dusty old skull.
Guys, Reuben tripped and fell down the stairs, guys.
There's this guy I'm meeting up with.
He was just so clumsy.
He's gonna trade me a diamond for it.
Being the resident go-getter pays off every once in a while.
Wait, that's worth a diamond?
Is a wither skull worth that much?
Are you kidding?
For all the trouble I had to go to get it, I should be asking for much more.
A single diamond.
What?
You could have farmed those diamonds yourselves.
You killed a wither skeleton.
I mean, I did build a super cool statue, but still.
It's pretty sweet being you, huh?
You know, you could come with me.
Me?
You think I'm cool and hot and like...
So brave?
All that you just said?
I'm all in.
You had me at female.
Consider it my charitable act for the day.
I'll consider it whatever you want me to consider it, as long as I get to come.
Keep the crafting table down there.
I'm like 10 right now.
Guys,
how do I make a sword?
Guys, I don't remember the crafting recipe.
Guys, what's the crafting recipe, guys?
Guys, I always have the fucking... the crafting book to my...
I always have the recipe book, guys.
Oh, fuck.
Is that a sword?
Oh, I did it!
I did it!
I'm so smart.
I knew it.
Look at that.
I'm a Minecraft-y.
I'm such a gamer.
Did we do it?
Wait, how do we know?
Good for you, Jesse.
Look at that.
See, guys?
I told you guys.
I told you we're winners.
No, he's an enabler.
He's got a buddy in his group just because he wanted to win.
Not a chance.
No, I can't tell her!
I'm not jealous or anything.
She's talking so much about Luka and I'm not jealous or anything.
And honestly, though, how did the fucking 2D creeper win?
Wait, what?
Those were torches!
They were torches, though!
Jump in the water!
There's no fall damage!
Oh, man.
We jump!
Oh my gosh, I finished a tutorial.
I look so fucking cool.
How would I fight?
But I'm a coward.
The thing is, I'm a coward.
Oh wait, hello there.
Goodbye, chickens.
Yay, free meat!
Wait, how the fuck did they live?
Oh my god, there's the bats!
Slap.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My room.
We're fucking glitched out there.
I need you to let me do the talking, okay?
I just don't want anything to screw this up.
I'll keep quiet, don't worry.
I'll let you handle it.
I'm less scared of you than scared for you.
We ran into each other while I was looking for Reuben.
He fell down a couple of stairs.
He was just being clumsy.
Right, Reuben?
It's okay, winning was much more important.
Why did it took- I could've covered it!
We had so much time!
Why did you not make it 3D?
Okay, we deserve a party, though.
I wanna party.
Also, like, the timing to make these choices is, like, instant.
I remember the Walking Dead, you had, like, an entire 30 fucking seconds to decide what to do.
And those were, like, life-death situations.
Oh shit, oh my gosh, shady deal in the alleyway.
For one singular diamond.
The very creepy alley.
Hmm...
A best character?
Wait...
Don't leave me here, I'm not scared or anything.
Wait, I'm not scared or anything, but, like, this is my first deal.
Wait, a chest.
What's in here?
Hello?
Don't... No, who are you?
Uno reverso.
I'm her bodyguard.
You want a wither skull.
You're the one that's screaming!
Of course I have it, I lied naturally.
You bet I wanna see it.
Sam, please...
He met first!
Like, what kind of... Why is there some weird tense yes performance anxiety?
Who are these people?
What do you mean by those people?
I'm cool if he's cool.
Yeah, as long as he doesn't fuck with the vibe, I'm cool.
I'm here to do the legal shit.
Oh, is it just in that chest?
I don't like how, like... Why is it not payment first?
It should always be payment first.
What is it?
He fucked us over!
He can't get away with this!
Yeah, chase him!
He can't go so far, he's old!
Where is he?
Oh, he's wearing a mask, I bet.
Okay, I can do this.
I can do this fast.
He has to be wearing a mask or something.
Hello?
Totally not here for anything illegal.
Oh my god, Gabriel!
Wait, I want her to go talk to Gabriel, though.
It's okay.
She'll understand.
She'll understand, guys.
Oh my god, my Oshie.
She'll understand.
She'll understand I got a little distracted.
Oh, it's Lucas!
What's up with you?
He has no biggie.
Just like, you know.
Didn't try that hard.
Your friend hurt my pig!
Hey, you didn't happen to see a creepy guy with long hair and a beard roaming around, did you?
You won't remember it.
No,
we're not!
Why do I get a choice to say no?
Coolio, too cool, cool beards!
I'm not gonna say anything.
What the fuck?
I can't say no, but I can say cool beards?
Let's fucking go.
Super cool beards.
What the fuck is this?
This is a chicken fighting ring?
What am I watching?
What are they watching?
The one-sided rivalry keeps going on.
Why?
Okay.
Okay, we can't find him alone, though.
No.
Oh my god, this is a chicken fighting ring.
Illegal.
Wait, which one is it?
I legitimately don't even remember what shirt he was wearing.
Hello, weirdo?
Oh!
How is this fuckhead?
Move, you idiot!
Yeah, that's right.
I'm here to start a fight.
Yeah!
Get the fuck away from me, you whore.
Nobody likes you, and you are definitely compensating for something.
Oh!
That's right.
Oh shit!
Guys, I'm not a creep, I'm sorry.
I thought you were a man.
Which would not help my case a lot, but if you don't understand, I got scammed.
Wait, fine.
Reuben's fine, right?
I bet he's- Oh, I have to interact with him.
Wait, is that Reuben?
Oh shit!
Oh wait, that was Reuben!
How did you take my pig?
Yeah, he's Chet.
Give him to me now.
Yeah, what are you gonna do?
What the fuck, you just picked up a random- I'm a friend with a sword.
That's right.
Violence is always the answer.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
My stone sword, that's very scary.
Guys, Reuben didn't remember that, so I'm in the clear.
Guys, he didn't remember it, guys, so he doesn't care.
He's fine.
Yeah, but he didn't remember it.
Any sign of him?
Oh, there he is!
I see him.
Wait, how the fuck did he get past?
What would it take to get us inside tonight?
What about pig?
Get out of our way!
I'm violent!
What are you gonna do?
You're one person.
What the fuck?
Who the fuck hired this guy?
Okay, we need to distract him.
Oh, we just hit the wall.
Well, they must have been an incredibly cheap usher.
It's not no-bill zone.
Wait,
I wanna- Okay, but I wanna burn some chickens real quick though.
Is that alright?
With you, buddy?
Oh, I can?
No!
The chicken man.
He's really, really into chicken.
Well, obviously I need to grab the slime block.
Get out of the way!
I need the slime block.
Hmm...
I bet I could reach that glass with a slime block.
Give me the slime block right now!
Oh, hey, we meet again.
One slime block, please.
We don't give out slime blocks here.
Just slime balls.
The fuck?
We've got a limited supply today and we're only giving out two per customer.
How many do I need?
You could craft your own slime block if you had nine slime balls.
I need slime.
Don't ask questions!
There's no time to explain.
What if I just break that guy's block?
Wait, what?
Where do I get the ninth?
Oh, this guy!
Lucas!
I need that slime!
Thanks, Lucas.
How do I make that?
You've got good chemistry.
Do I just put it like that?
Three, six...
I'm just saying, I think it's cool you have a team that works so well together.
You're totally jealous.
How's it going, Jesse?
You know how to do this.
Is this a slime block?
Oh, I did it!
Ta-da!
One slime block.
Gross.
I'll take that.
Right... there.
It's all you, Jesse.
Give me a boost.
Oh my god, look at that go.
Parkour!
It's crafting time.
And then I'm going to craft over this place.
Oh shit!
Look at that.
Parkour.
Freedom!
Why did he run into the chickens?
Wait, what?
How would you know?
It's just an open door.
Anybody could open that door.
What is he going to do?
We're going to show him to not piss off us 12 year olds.
Like, how old are we in this game?
That's right.
We are a gang of 12 year olds.
Wait, we're not thieves?
Oh, that's so true.
I do.
Yeah!
Anarchy!
Exactly!
Why do we have to be a good tool of criminal?
Right, Lucas?
I know you'd believe in me.
Alright, I'm going to steal bookcases.
It's very hard to make a crafting table.
Not crafting, uh, enchanted table.
Alright, what are you stealing?
See, I knew you were into stealing.
Wait, is that a diamond sword?
Is that a sword?
What sword is that?
Is that gold?
A sword is a sword.
Is there anything else I can steal?
What did you get, Axel?
You mean the water potion?
One of them just looks like water.
Oh, I'm stealing this.
What is that potion?
That's mine.
Get out of here.
I had the idea first.
There's no way he'll know.
Wait, what are you stealing, Olivia?
Oh, that's why he needs the Wither Skull, right?
To enchant.
Oh, Reuben, are you okay?
Where are you gonna steal?
What's that?
Oh, the lever.
I mean, I was gonna push the lever anyway.
Lucas, don't be a nerd.
Steal something.
We're all doing it.
We're all in this together.
Okay, let's pull this lever.
Whoa, what's that?
Oh, isn't that the Power Stone or whatever?
Oh, it's a config.
Oh my god, we're hacking in.
Oh my god, it's a config block.
It's like a bad block.
It's a machine.
Time to put it in creative mode.
I'm here to hack now.
What the hell?
Yeah, it was...
Maybe he's a collector?
You make banners?
That's...
Oh, but what happens if you add the command block?
Wait, but what happens with a command block?
Okay, hide in the chest.
There's no way he'll find me.
Why did we not grab...
Wait.
Oh,
he wants revenge on Gabriel.
Wait, isn't he the wizard?
He's the wizard.
That's him.
Why did he not get famous?
Is it because he's a fucking creep?
Must be like some fucking creep if he didn't get famous like everybody else.
I say nothing.
Goodbye, Olivia.
Leave her alone!
Yeah!
What?
She wouldn't remember it.
Why did no one else do it?
You have been voted off the island, Olivia.
Give me my diamond.
I don't care about the wizard.
Look, she's dead weight anyway.
She got Kai.
Enough!
You've wasted too much of my time already.
Where'd he go?
Wait, what?
Just a snowman.
Am I gonna be afraid?
Oh, what?
Oh, never mind.
I forgot that's Iron Golem.
That's the Iron Golem recipe.
That's snow blocks, right guys?
Forget!
What happens if I get smacked?
Oh, I'm okay.
I didn't even get hit!
It's fine.
We got you, Ruben.
A very buff snowman.
Yeah, we just stacked two blocks.
Ooh, Gabriel!
Gabriel!
It was a really buff snowman.
I don't need Gabriel!
Woo!
Should we warn Gabriel of the creepy guy that wanted to kill him?
Nah, it'll be fine.
He's still down there.
Don't worry!
I shall be a hero!
We don't need Gabriel!
I'll be the next Gabriel!
I'm a hero.
That's right.
I'm gonna be a fucking hero.
Watch this.
Ruben, what the fuck are you doing here?
Leave.
Move over.
That's right.
Oh, she right there.
That is exactly why I'm not letting Gabriel take all of my credit.
Can I die from the Iron Golem?
Oh, X-Spread Dog, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Get out of here!
Just need to build three blocks.
What's he gonna do, kill me?
Slap me again!
Don't die!
Other than the time I did die.
I'm going to attack him.
Watch this.
Tell my story.
I'm just gonna do it.
Yeah, that's right.
Look, look at me.
Look at me.
I'm looking.
Look at me, I'm right here.
Turn around!
Look at me!
I'm right here, look at me!
Oh shit, I was supposed to look there.
That's what I do.
That's right, fuck you!
That's fucking right.
Okay.
Yeah!
That's right, hit me again!
Huzzah, you got it!
Hit me again.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
No man left behind.
Apparently, I didn't say no woman when I let Olivia get caught.
We take this.
Yeah, Olivia's not a man.
Oh,
there he is.
Does he not recognize him?
His voice?
I didn't know we were into that fight.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Daniel, thank you for the super chat.
That's the guy who attacked us!
That's why I'm ratting him out right now.
There's a different story?
They all work together?
How is the story different?
Somebody stop him!
Okay, that did nothing.
Nothing built can last forever, Gabriel.
What does he do with the command block?
Oh my god, he's commanding it!
Oh my god, that's what the slash attack!
That's right, do it again!
What if I...
Slash pop attack!
What's he gonna do, kill me?
Slash attack!
Do it!
I'm a tank, guys.
You can tank those, you have a... you literally have a desert army.
Oh my god, he has admin!
Slash retreat!
Oh no.
Wait, is that not the command?
Slash retreat!
Command error.
The command is right, he forgot the command!
He forgot the command!
Add slash E4, E4!
He forgot the slash!
Oh my god, I will be admin!
No!
What do you mean actions have consequences?
It's a Telltale game, what do you mean?
I wanted... okay, let him fly out.
Let him fly, I want to see what happens when he flies.
Let him fly into the wither!
Let him fly in!
That's where the guy that said he's their oshi.
I have to save him?
No, fly!
Fly into that wither!
Oh my god, I can't believe I actually have to save him.
Oh my god, if I fell it just like that makes me do it again.
I want to know what it looks like!
No!
Why does it have to be a canon event?
What if I don't say anything?
What?
Only winners write the history.
I'm not evil if I win.
How do I command block that?
Okay, we just need an admin.
We just need a moderator to get on the server and do slash ban.
Guys, no man left behind!
Guys!
What happened?
What if I get sucked up?
Suck me?
Come on!
I want to be one with the wither!
Let me be one with the wither!
How much time do they give?
Yeah!
Is that how I die?
You died.
You don't know that!
I could be a part of the wither!
Guys, come on.
There was so much time to save me too.
I had like a solid 20 seconds to be saved.
Alright, nice.
Hello, I'm okay.
Guys, if you were worried, I'm okay.
Wait, so all these people died in front of me?
That's what you get?
Wait, if I died there...
It's like the Heavy Rain gameplay where I just fail all my quick time events.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's what you get for trying to kill my Oshie.
Oh no.
Don't worry, I'm holding on!
I did it, guys!
Become one with the wither.
I'm a hero.
We didn't die, technically.
Yeah, I did it, guys!
All me!
What did I just...
What happens?
I
did it by doing nothing at all!
No punishment.
What did I just... Oh shit!
It's okay, I can climb out!
Yeah!
It was a cannon.
No consequences!
Let's go!
Okay, I won't follow them.
They look more confident.
I mean, they literally have Gabriels there.
Oh my god, goodbye, creeper.
Oh no!
Oh fuck, okay.
I died.
Okay, apparently that has consequences.
Wait, can I go in the... Oh my god, you're right!
Wait, what happens if I go in the middle?
I don't know, I thought they would give me no consequences!
Okay, let me fall back in the hole again.
Wait, what happens if I go in the middle?
Do I just run through the... I just run through the forest?
Alright, what happens?
Oh, I just go left.
Yeah, I follow the winners.
Okay, now I actually have to move, guys.
Alright, don't worry.
See, Reuben?
That's how you take the fire, Reuben!
Okay, I had to dodge that.
I didn't know if I would die.
Wait, what if I don't die?
Look at that, I'm fine.
Just a little HP loss.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck, he's gonna eat me!
Oh, okay.
Okay, everything.
Everybody is fine.
Okay, now I know.
Oh, I got this.
Okay, watch this.
I pressed it!
Okay, this is fine.
I figured it out.
Look, see?
Oh, epic dodge.
Oh my god!
Oh, so cool.
Okay, now watch this.
There we go.
I look so cool there.
Hurry!
Inside the temple!
The inner chamber is built entirely of obsidian.
We should be untouchable in there.
Tom, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I love the way you laugh.
Thank you!
I'm glad you enjoyed my laugh!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh wait, are we going to the nether?
Hurry!
If you can get through the portal, you'll be safe!
It's not lit!
I have a flint and steel!
I'm sorry.
Yeah?
If we die, we all die together.
Gabriel!
I was just thinking... I just want to die with my friends.
Let him die.
Goodbye.
Wait, not me!
Not me!
I just wanted him to die!
Everyone, get in!
Now!
Alright, we got this.
Gabriel!
Don't worry!
Look at that!
It looks so cool!
First try!
I wanted good nether radar, mate.
Oh no, definitely the casualty rate is 90%.
Others?
There were four of them.
So there's only one more person.
Wait, how would I find them?
Oh shit.
Sorry.
What if I don't say anything?
No!
Don't be a hero!
Don't be stupid!
Okay.
Alright, I guess I'll go.
Alright, we gotta go to the portal.
Lucas, go to the portal, Lucas!
Who do I save?
I'm saving Gabriel.
One has misery armor!
The other one is holding a gold sword!
No!
No man left behind!
One was literally holding a gold sword!
Who do you think I'm gonna save?
We did everything we could.
He froze.
Guys, we did everything we could, guys.
Guys, Gabriel had netherite armor and a netherite diamond sword!
She had no armor and a gold sword that she stole.
She's dead.
She's most likely dead.
She doesn't have a bed.
E-boy?
Yeah, is that one killed the ender dragon?
The other is a criminal.
Oh shit.
That's illegal!
I've ruined everything!
You stole first!
Punch him.
I'mma punch him.
I talk in violence.
I'm alpha now.
That's right.
It made me feel better.
Wait, I saved him.
Oh, so she's alive!
See guys?
I told you!
She's alive!
Guys, I did not... See?
I didn't fuck up.
Alright,
we should listen to him.
He's right.
She can't remember that!
She's not even here!
She's not even here to know I didn't defend her.
Oh my god, is that an invisibility potion?
See?
I told you.
Hitting him was the way to go.
Melting?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh shit, it's a ghast.
Look, she had a gold sword!
What the fuck am I gonna do with someone with a gold sword?
It's okay, I'm just gaining level up experience every time.
I'm getting XP.
The more things I tank.
Oh my god, it's like a rollercoaster.
Put your hands up.
Hands in the air!
Woo!
Yippee!
Yay!
Oh my god, it's okay, it's okay guys.
I don't have a concussion guys, I don't need to see a doctor.
The more hits I get, the more immune I will be for more damage.
Oh, arms don't fail me now.
We can all die together.
Where did everybody go?
My actions have consequences?
Oh shit.
I got you!
I got you, Ruben!
Okay, I need to look at him.
I see Ruben!
I was gonna save you.
I did it, I'm a hero!
Oh my god, I did it!
See, if I didn't duck, how would I have known?
Ow, okay, wait.
Give me a sec, I can time this.
Look at that.
Ow, okay, look at that.
I can time this, guys.
Now for the actual gameplay.
Boom!
Oh my god, he's back.
Where are your children?
So I can kidnap them.
Oh, Ruben!
Hey guys, what are you guys doing?
I handled it.
Yeah, I was doing a great job.
Yeah, right, Ruben?
We were so cool.
Ruben, why are you mad?
I saved your life!
I saved your life, Ruben!
After the skeleton guy shot a couple of arrows, but I still do it.
Still did it!
Why is he mad?
Ruben remembers.
How does he remember?
He's a pig.
There's the portal.
There it is.
That's our way out.
How many blocks away are we in the overworld?
The surface is also where that creature is.
He's right.
We have no idea what we're walking into.
It could be dangerous.
Well, slash command block.
Slash delete.
Thanks for being so brave, Axel.
Alright, I'm gonna go.
I'm going.
I'm going right now.
You got this!
Like right, right now.
Stop stalling.
I just need to make sure I have everything I'll need.
Stop stalling?
Yeah!
You said you would go!
Exactly!
Don't push me, okay?
Here I go.
See, he did remember it.
Right behind you.
Be safe up there, Axel.
Ready or not, here I come.
Look, this is life or death, guys.
Only I can saw him, the main character.
He's just a side character.
Alright, who wants to go next, guys?
Guys, does anyone else want to go next?
Does anyone else?
Woah!
Hey guys, ladies first!
Look, see?
He's okay.
See?
He was okay, guys.
Don't worry, I got you, Axel.
See?
I'm a hero.
What was I looking at?
Why did I look at there?
No, Ivar said...
Let them argue!
Let them fight!
What is it?
Oh...
Do we actually agree on something?
What?
In a hut, we won't know what's coming until it's knocking on our door.
I want a hut!
I hate spiders.
I want to build a dirt house.
It's not...
That's it, Olivia.
Jesse made the call.
That's right, I'm the leader.
Get started.
I want to live in a dirt hut.
Like a true king.
Okay, let's go fast.
Oh my god, it's beautiful.
Okay, this is a little too big for a dirt house.
It's okay, we'll just look outside.
Return to the dirt house.
See, look at that.
Everything's fine.
How do we have fire on cement?
On stone?
What is it?
Oh!
For me.
Yay!
What?
Watch me eat this cookie, Lucas.
Watch me eat it.
That's right, Lucas.
Why is it up to me to share the cookie?
There's four of us.
She could've shared the cookie.
Olivia could've shared it.
She would've liked it.
Stop being mean to Lucas.
Guys, I'm not just mean.
I'm mean to everybody in this game.
It's all equal.
I'm not targeting anyone.
He was just there.
Fight!
Yeah.
Don't keep fighting.
Silent treatment.
Why do they keep fighting?
Wait.
No, no, you're staying with us.
I need you to...
I need him to keep fighting.
I need more people to torment.
Stay.
So I can eat another cookie in front of you.
I need more drama.
I'm keeping him prisoner.
Finally a good choice.
No worries.
You're my entertainment.
He chose to be evil.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No man left behind, guys.
Hey, is everything okay?
What if I say nothing to him?
I don't even comfort him.
Oh, shit.
I did it.
He's just like, thanks, Jesse, for saying nothing.
Guys, don't need words to be understood, guys.
He saw it in my eyes.
He knew I was sorry.
Great.
He saw it in my eyes.
We don't need words.
What are you waiting for?
Let's go.
He's a true bro.
He looked into my eyes and realized...
I was sorry.
It's a bro thing, guys.
It's a bro code.
Yeah, it's in my little trinket.
CB Raricle, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Yeah, we are.
Are these arrows?
Hey, guys, don't worry.
I got this.
I'm a hero.
I'm the protagonist.
We got this, guys.
Hey, Reuben, you still have your black eye.
Oh, no.
Run!
No, an arrow.
It's okay, guys.
I'm...
Okay, three arrows.
Okay, it's three arrows, guys.
I figured it out.
I didn't know this.
I thought I could take it all.
Don't worry.
I got it now.
Who would have thought arrows hurt?
Don't worry.
I know it's three arrows now.
See, look.
There you go.
I live.
Wait, again?
Don't keep commanding your troops in World War 2.
Dot, dot, dot.
Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What do we use first?
Oh, the door.
Wait, is it a fishing rod?
What do I do?
Does this make anything?
What?
Is this something?
Oh, wait.
This is arrow, right?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Guys, I always knew.
Guys, guys, I always knew.
Guys, uh...
Okay.
I figured it out.
Look, see?
Here's our bow.
I did it!
And then...
And then feather here.
So it makes like an arrow.
Yay!
Are we creating... how many arrows do I have?
I'm curious.
Oh, I can hit... I can only hit that.
Okay, I was gonna say.
What if I use it all up?
I did it, guys.
I'll just use up all my arrows and then I wanna see how they respond to that.
Oh, there's the enchantment room.
What would I enchant, though?
Oh, that's his... is this his area?
He just recreated it?
Guys, remember what we did?
We stole stuff.
Let's recreate that.
Oh,
look.
There's the enchantment book.
Oh, there were five?
I thought he was the wizard, but older and he got creepier.
He was written out of history.
Wait, Gabriel didn't mention this.
Oh, so he was the support player.
He was their support.
Oh my god, he fucked over the healing.
Now do it again.
Oh my god, he pissed off the healer.
You never piss off the healer.
They're the most spiteful ones.
I say as I'm a healer, man.
No, we are very spiteful people.
We go up.
Wasn't like... wasn't like Pirate Software the support in their group, too?
Gabriel?
No, he was the mage?
I thought he was... because I knew he was the magic user.
Is something supposed to happen?
Because I was going to say, if he was the support, it makes more sense.
Where's the order?
I'm calling the order out.
Don't worry, I tried everything I could to save her.
Whoa!
They were everywhere.
Where was me?
Where's me?
Where am I in this area?
Yeah.
Hey, Reuben.
What are you doing there, little guy?
Sniff out.
Sniff them out for me.
Reuben?
No wonder you die.
Who'd have thought it, huh?
A bunch of small towners like us wrapped up in an adventure like this.
Yeah, it's pretty insane.
I just hope we all come out the other side in one piece.
Oh, okay.
Do I just put stuff there?
Guys, I'm only joking.
He's gonna live for a very long time, guys.
I would never let anything hurt Reuben.
Good.
Let me put this in there.
Yeah.
Put the amulet on here.
Oh, and then the sun shines through it and it's gonna show where they live.
Yeah.
Oh!
Okay.
Puzzle time.
What do I do here?
Okay.
Oh my god, okay.
Guys, this is a children's game.
There's no way I can mess this up.
This is a... There's no way.
Oh my god, Nimi!
Thank you for the raid!
I hope you enjoyed Elden Ring!
I'm figuring this out, guys.
There's no way a child can beat this game.
What if I just turn them all on?
Wait.
What do the lights mean?
What do they mean?
Okay.
Let's turn this off.
Guys, don't... No, we're not gonna be here forever.
I'm figuring this out.
Okay, that doesn't do anything.
I did it!
Wait, what is this?
I just turned it on and off!
What did that mean?
What?
Oh, this is a tracking system.
Yeah.
I cracked the code.
Just turn it on and off, guys.
What do we know?
We have to stop Ivor.
Guys, she doesn't need our help.
It's fine.
She's a strong, independent woman.
She'll want us to stop the villain.
Wait,
what?
Oh, yeah.
Sora was just... I bet he's like missing in the nether or something.
Yeah, her gold sword will keep her safe.
No, Lucas, come with us.
Yeah, we need you with us.
Don't worry.
There's a reason why I kept you.
Wait, what the fuck?
Lucas, I need drama!
Wait, what?
Wait, who was the other guy?
Is it the other guy?
Oh, that's...
Okay.
Alright, guys.
Do we get the one with the master degree?
Or the one that goes big boom?
You know what I'm gonna pick, guys.
You know exactly which one I'm gonna pick.
Let me pick!
Guys, he brings the big boom.
She was like... Olivia's like, you're my best friend.
And I'm like, boom.
I'm only doing this for Petra.
I'll take it.
I'm here for the big boom.
Uh, guys?
Huh?
Oh, there he is.
There's slash command... slash command block.
Please hurry.
I did it!
Oh wait, is that episode one?
Oh my god, each episode is like an hour and a half long.
Oh my god.
I did it!
Okay, refresh to download.
See more choice.
Wait, I have episode two.
Oh wait.
Continue.
Where's episode two?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, okay.
I already have episode two.
Don't worry.
Okay, how do I skip this?
Okay.
Does it go straight to episode two?
Yeah, there we go.
Oh my god, thank god.
I was like...
I was gonna be a little worried.
I was gonna be like, okay, wait a minute.
I thought I downloaded all of it.
Okay, episode two.
How many episodes are there?
I got worried there too.
There's eight?!
But what about season one?
Okay, five for season one.
I tried everything I could to save her, guys.
We're gonna get big explody, man.
Things will be fine.
I believe.
Yeah, you know what?
You're right.
Why we gotta be boring while we're trying to save the world?
Yeah!
If we put enough dynamite, he might die!
Dynamite solves everything.
Whoa.
So many deaths.
Can't wait to kidnap your kids.
Ow!
Ow, that stings!
He knows.
He heard the new Minecraft update.
But what do I use?
Do I set my bow and arrow?
Do I- Am I looking at Reuben?
Am I gonna chuck Reuben?
Reuben?
Okay, I got a sword.
If I don't swing, I technically can't miss.
Okay, maybe the arrow.
Come on, Reuben.
Gonna be heroes!
Yeah, we don't need that ammo, guys.
We'll just make more.
Oh my god, it's called Boomtown!
Okay.
I can't believe it.
We're...
We're fighting- We're going to the birthplace of the Costco, guys.
Boomtown brings the boom.
We're going to where they- Their origin story.
Wait, what the fuck?
Is that all they do in Boomtown?
They just throw dynamite?
Oh my god, this place is perfect.
Perfect.
It's practically paradise.
The oldest anarchy server in Minecraft.
Wait!
He just- Yes, you think he's- No, no, he respawns, right, guys?
Guys, he respawns, right?
He's gonna- He's gonna respawn, right?
Wait, this is where I live.
We're in the old Wild West.
What?
What are they doing?
A griefer!
Oh my god, oh, they're griefers.
You're right, this is hardcore mode.
No respawn.
Jesus Christ, that's hardcore.
What happens in Boomtown stays in Boomtown.
Yeah, adventure mode, hardcore only, no respawn.
That's right.
You don't know jack shit, Jesse.
How do I get out of here?
Where do I go?
Do I go backwards?
You might be wondering how I got here.
Oh,
banner wall.
Boomtown.
Do all these belong to different griefers?
It's pretty exciting.
Yeah, I like it here.
I wanna live here.
Yeah,
the possibility of just dying?
So exciting.
And you just never come back?
I've done this before.
Oh!
Oh, it's like a little detector.
Right here.
Oh, wait, wait.
It's here.
The big boom.
Oh no, it's a griefer.
Wait,
why would you wanna know?
What did Magnus do?
Oh, noobs.
Alright, who wants to help us?
The crit.
Sounds complicated.
Oh, I thought I was gonna make them fight each other.
Bunch of noobs.
Every cringe makes me stronger.
Oh, it hurts.
I knew this town wasn't perfect.
There's always one flaw.
It's inhabited by children.
I knew it.
The one flaw.
The egg.
That's a chicken egg.
Get over here.
That's right, superhero landing.
Landing.
Ruben, go!
Chase after her!
Alex, what the fuck were you- Axel, what the fuck were you doing?
Your one job was to get- I got two people!
Oh my god.
The one flaw in Boom Town.
I have children playing mobile Minecraft right now.
Alright, up I go.
Up I go.
Oh.
It's okay, I can- I died?!
To be fair, I had no armor.
I had no armor.
Okay, that makes sense, guys.
I was not wearing any armor.
I don't know, I thought I could take it!
I take the chicken egg!
He died with a big boom.
I thought it would take me five booms!
And uh, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Five big booms worth a quick time event, VTuber.
Don't worry, I got this.
First try.
What?
It's the egg's fault, it got me low HP, guys.
I couldn't take it.
Yeah.
Yeah, the chicken egg does just a little bit damage than TNT in comparison.
Oh, she's just like me.
Give me that.
Wait, what happens?
What happens?
That's right.
See, I take that!
Oh shit, I want that.
Boink, mine now!
Oh shit, jump!
Oh shit, wait, how did they know?
How did they know I was there?
We just need to get to the spire.
It's my amulet.
It's mine.
Oh my.
That's right.
My precious amulet.
What's he gonna remember?
He's not gonna remember shit.
He knows what his role is.
See, I'm okay.
See what he's gonna do, shoot me in the head?
See, look at that.
No consequences.
There's actual no consequences.
What am I not gonna happen?
I fall?
Oh.
Guys, okay, there's one consequence.
There's one consequence, apparently.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know I fall.
See, that changes nothing!
That really changes nothing!
I still get hit by the arrow.
I did.
I pressed all the buttons for you.
Everything go okay?
Well, welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Yes, I got it.
Wait, the arrow's still in my knee.
You think there's consequences?
There's no way.
Wait, Reuben, you're better now!
Your eye's healed!
Just knock on the door.
Let me in!
I'm important!
Oh, wait, it worked.
So it seems.
Let's get in there.
Right behind you.
That's a shitty trap.
Doesn't even lead us directly to lava.
Magnus?
What?
We're not griefers!
Hey!
You can't insult him!
Yeah, I can!
How?
He doesn't even have a fucking... the eye shit.
He's definitely... he's your biggest fan.
How is that an insult?
What do you mean, like... what do you...
I wasn't even insulting him!
Gabriel sent us.
He's like, well, I'm not really that big of a fan.
Did I call him fat?
Is that... did I accidentally call him fat?
I just meant he was... you're like... he was his, like, goshi.
Wait, what's that?
I accidentally called... I didn't realize that's what it means!
Oh, shit!
I didn't... I didn't know!
I didn't remember!
I didn't realize!
Whoops.
I didn't realize what he said!
Look at him!
I thought he was like, yes, he obviously is wearing green.
I thought it was because he was wearing green!
I thought you were a hero.
I don't know.
No!
Don't remember, Taxel!
I swear to God!
That was not taxed!
I thought it was because he was wearing green!
I'll just let it ramble.
Yikes!
Let's not go down that road.
Okay, okay, you sold me!
I didn't say anything!
Oh, but we might have a little bit of a problem getting out of here.
Huh?
You're Magnus.
You can just walk out of here.
Yeah, but why did all the griefers want to kill him?
I don't know if you've looked around this place, but it's kind of full of griefers.
But that's kind of awesome, right?
Yeah, isn't that great?
Anarchy.
You've heard about the whole challenging the king for his crown thing, right?
That's why I want to kill him.
So long as I'm king, I can't leave this town.
But you're king, you just make new rules.
No, you don't!
They're no match for you!
Take them all down!
No one can beat you.
And that's the problem.
Simply put, that's life as king of Boomtown.
Not as fun as you'd think.
Choose a new king.
I do get to spit on their heads occasionally, so I guess that's something.
Just choose a new king and then have fun.
You can't just choose a new king, Doki!
I've beaten them dozens of times.
And none are worthy!
They'll see right through it.
But you, you're the newcomer with the golden amulet.
By now there'll probably be all sorts of rumors about how awesome you are.
If you beat me, then I'll be able to leave.
Can't believe I didn't think of it before!
Wait, how do I beat you though?
How would I ever beat you?
I know, right?
But that's just it.
You won't have to.
I'm faking it!
Just like on Moonland!
What?
Death Ball!
Love!
I'll graze you!
Okay!
I'll graze you with TNT.
Oh my god, yeah, let's do it!
Fuck it, let's wing it!
There's too many choices, guys!
I didn't know!
There's so many choices!
They were all great!
The Ocelot Slayer.
That's right.
You hear that, Lucas?
Fuck you!
You heard the name, folks.
Even if you're not here, I'm still gonna fuck with you.
Opponents will craft their own griefing towers, which they will then use to grief each other.
The only rule is...
That there are no rules!
No eye poking!
Other than that, go crazy!
Seriously.
Ocelot Slayer!
That's me!
Nah, I'm good.
Brought my own supply.
Let the griefing begin!
Wait, who's checking his supply?
Okay, what do I want?
Pink wool?
What?
I want pink wool.
Pink wool it is!
The least explosive material, guys.
Pink wool!
Not bad.
Guess it'll have to do.
It's very threatening.
Axel, what are you doing over there on his side?
Yeah, thought you might bring that up.
It's just that Ruben wanted to take your corner, and I didn't want to crowd him or anything, so I thought I'd watch from over here.
He doesn't trust me!
After everything I did!
And I totally didn't fat shame him.
I thought it was because he was wearing green, guys!
Get out of here.
I knew it!
That's right.
Fuck you!
Yeah!
Pussy!
Oh my god!
Wait!
That chick is dead!
Oh!
I need a time to look down!
The tactical pause!
Pause!
Okay.
Holding the lever.
My turn!
Oh shit!
He can do that?!
You can do that?!
Oh, now you're on my side!
Wait.
What about the plan?
Oh, I thought he was going to say it out loud!
I wanted everyone to be like, what do you mean, plan?
Guys, you gotta make it look real!
Guys, he's just trying to make it look real!
What do I have?
Oh, okay.
Let's put some rocks here.
What am I making?
How would that... I have a square-shaped hole!
What the fuck?
Oh shit!
It goes in the squirrel!
It's okay.
I dodged!
Guys, look!
I did it!
I had a feeling I would actually die!
What's Ruben gonna do?
Oh shit!
I look really cool!
Yeah, I have this part of your animal that's gonna fuck you up!
A bow and arrow?
I light it with the lava!
Ruben!
Axel, get him!
What if I just shoot him?
Look at that!
Slow-mo!
Oh shit!
Where's my 360?
Oh, he's dead-dead.
It would be funny if Magnus just dies and then it's like...
We accidentally just kill someone in the order.
That's me!
Yippee!
I'm a hero!
Hello, Boomtown!
That's right!
Now they're like, thank God!
I am now the new-oh!
Just throw a dynamite at it!
I guess he dies.
Alright, rest in peace Boomtown!
Goodbye!
Is he gonna-is he gonna get hit?
Bye, Radimuses that were gonna kill me!
I feel so sorry for you.
Oh, Boomtown went boom!
No!
Did I make that?
Who made that?
Oh, Lucas!
You made that?
Wait, did you build all this?
Guys, see?
I told you keeping Lucas around was a good idea.
Olivia could never do something like this.
I forgot he was a builder.
Wait, I gotta use the bathroom.
I'm worried that, like, if I leave it running while I use the bathroom, I'm gonna make a hundred million choices and I don't know what happens.
So, I'll be right back!
Alright, let me double check something real quick.
Alright.
Let us keep playing, as in play.
Let's just keep watching.
I got my Costco tacos too.
My Costco chicken tacos, if you know what I mean.
Gabriel!
He's back!
Coyote, Johnny, Flo, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
See, guys?
I saved the real hero.
I saved the right person.
Wait, how did you escape?
Yeah!
See, guys?
He would've been dead!
Oh, shit.
Yeah, anyone else live?
No, she's fine.
She's fine.
He's lying.
There's no way.
There's no way!
He's lying, guys!
Actions don't have consequences in my Telltale game.
Oh, she found him?
Isn't that Elgar the engineer?
Yeah, what's wrong with her?
It's Elgar the redstone engineer.
Well, if you're such a big fan, then why don't you go hang out with her then?
Jesse!
Look!
I found Elgar!
Just hang on a sec, okay?
I'll go figure out what's going on.
Good, you do that.
Look, redstones are for nerds, okay?
Why come up with all this technology when I can just throw a dynamite at it?
Who are you now?
And why did you bring him with you?
We're reuniting.
Magnus is awesome.
He's just awesome.
I could give a real accent, but it's them like, bro, Magnus is awesome.
Who needs inventions when I can throw a bomb at it?
Everything explodes.
I'm the king of Boomtown.
Yeah, I'm king.
What are you, Olivia?
Not even the queen of Redstone Town.
Hello, Magnus.
Your voice is exactly as pleasant as I remember.
Which is to say, not at all.
Oh, my feelings.
Is that the same wit you're going to use to save the world?
Why?
You here to tell me how to do it better?
Oh, I would never dream of doing that.
Unlike you, I actually do things instead of just talking.
Hey, that's enough of what you're talking about.
Show her some respect.
Wow, you finally found yourself a live one.
Hey, your little devotees are usually a little more on the bookish side.
Leave that to Magnus.
This is between the two of us.
Oh, I started worrying.
You're just a big hothead stomping in here.
Easy there, Olivia.
He's a pain in the butt, but he's still an old acquaintance.
People, can we please focus on the bigger picture?
We have a very hungry Witherstorm in the process of turning the whole world into its dinner.
Guys, did you forget the world's ending?
That thing looked real nasty.
And I've seen some nasty stuff in my time.
Too much for you, was it?
Your usual brutish approach didn't cut it.
Wait, why did it go after Boomtown and not Redstone City?
That's fucked up.
Fuck!
That's so fucked up.
Boomtown's already going through it.
It did not need more destroying.
So what are you gonna do?
Wait, I thought you were heroes.
Yeah.
No, you're supposed to know right away what to do.
I put you on a pedestal.
So all my expectations will never be matched.
Wait, something that can be stronger than TNT?
That's possible?
Wait, he's not the TNT- oh my god, a nuke?
The F-bomb.
F-bomb, okay.
The fuck-bomb.
Okay.
Yeah, if I found Elegard too.
Not the F-bomb, she says naturally.
Not the F-bomb in my fucking Minecraft game.
Wait, he wasn't on the map.
Yeah, how do we find him?
Is he in the nether?
He has to be in the nether, right?
That's why he's not on the map, because this doesn't show the nether.
Like, where else would it be?
Oh no.
Okay, let me finesse my hat underneath the tray.
Sorry for my eating ASMR.
Hey.
See, I told you!
You're his biggest fan!
You were like, I'm not that tall.
Hey, what is Elegard?
I've never talked to her before.
Did not activate- I don't remember how to activate it.
What did I do?
All your friends are dead, but you're doing great.
Keep it together.
Okay?
I need you here.
I need the drama in my life.
Don't worry, you're strong.
I believe in you.
Okay, we put this on.
I should not have to do the switches, right?
Oh no.
Oh no, guys, I don't...
I don't remember the switches.
Okay.
Okay, wait, no, I don't!
It's already turned on!
What?
Okay, nice.
I just need to turn one button.
What?
Wait,
what?
What?
How did he show up?
Wait, what's the problem?
Yeah.
Oh shit.
What?
Who's that?
Is that Ivor?
Ivor?
Sorry, I...
Sorry, I didn't realize his name is Ivor.
Well,
just bring torches!
Now we should go now!
Well, just bring torches!
What's the worst that could happen?
I trust the boom guy.
He doesn't need a degree.
He has street smart.
We don't need a master's degree to figure this out.
We just have torches, right?
Guys, where's our torches?
Guys?
Where's our torches, guys?
Yeah, I'm pretty fucking tough.
Yeah, that's me.
I think that's hot.
What?
Whoa!
Yeah, she's kind of...
Why do I just throw a defender?
I want it!
What if I don't?
Let her...
Let her overthink.
Now she's gonna overthink this forever.
Now she'll never know.
She's gonna overthink this and be like, isn't me?
Now she's insecure.
Yeah.
I told you guys we should have brought torches.
Get over here.
Okay.
I got this, guys.
Boom!
Oh, fuck!
There we go.
We did it.
Look at him go!
We got this!
Boom!
What a badass.
God, I'm such a gamer.
Guys, do you think the final battle is gonna be like Mass Effect where my choices matter and if I piss off everybody, I'm just gonna solo it?
There's no way, right?
My choices don't matter, right?
My actions don't have consequences.
Nah.
Sorin?
Are you here?
We're here for the F-bomb.
I knew getting Magnus here was a good idea.
He's so healthy.
Oh, shit.
Oh!
Wait, that can happen?
Oh, my God, Enderman!
I thought I was eating my taco.
Oh,
hey, Lucas!
Hey, we're too alone to get there.
I didn't think they ever came in groups that big.
Wait, thanks for coming back.
Yeah, where are the others?
Wait, actually...
They left me to die?
Oh, they thought I was ahead?
Oh, I didn't think I was ahead!
I was behind them!
Okay.
Wait, if he grabs me, will I just hit two feet out?
Yeah, there's no way he'll hit me, right?
Oh, wait, they don't like water.
Ruben!
Jump, Ruben!
They don't care about pigs, but jump anyway!
I need you to drown with me.
Just like the Egyptians.
Oh, it's right here.
What?
Wait, what?
Why are they angry?
Oh, they're searching on both sides!
Wouldn't it be in the one where the white area is?
For Soren?
Yeah, they like to fight a lot.
Yeah, they're like an old married couple.
I bet you they'll hook up later.
They have history.
You can tell.
Where's the one that's white?
Blue...
Oh, I have to open all of them, maybe?
Talk to me.
Wait, what happened, Gabriel?
Wait, why are you sick?
Yeah, what happened?
Did you get bit?
Oh my god, he got
you!
He's one of those!
He doesn't tell you when he gets bit!
Oh my god, it's the Walking Dead all over again!
He's one of them!
Not again, Lee!
Toki will remember that.
I'm gonna remember that.
Wait, is this actually Lee's voice acting?
That's so funny!
I would absolutely not endanger the group, guys.
I would never!
I can't believe it!
I can't believe he didn't talk!
Alright, let's go get Magnus.
Wait, what?
Okay, who do we follow?
Oh, you know how we followed Magnus.
Leave no man behind.
Oh my god, he's gonna tell me.
He's gonna turn!
I'm aware that letting them head off alone is risky, but I need to talk to you about a private matter.
It's not the easiest thing to bring up.
I can't believe it!
I don't want to worry the others.
Okay, whatever it is, I trust you.
You can tell me.
Yeah, you fucking traitor.
Thank you for being so understanding.
People remember that.
I'm so glad to see my old friends together again.
He's gonna remember that before he dies.
What?
What is that?
Wither sickness?
Yeah, I was like, what's the difference?
What?
What does it do?
Wait, just drink milk!
You're just 1 HP, you're fine!
Creeper, look out!
Take my head!
Just drink some milk!
My strength is compromised!
Sorry, I was eating my taco again.
Are you alright?
I was eating my taco again.
Go and find the others.
Hopefully you can find a way to get down to me or something.
Time to be a hero again.
Stay safe!
I'll find a way down to you!
No taco time!
Every time I fall down a hole, I'm eating my taco.
We got cut in his arm!
It happened to his arm again!
Lee!
How was I supposed to know I was going to fall down again?
Where did I go?
I guess here?
Hello?
Sorin?
Are you here?
Please, get over here.
Do you have any milk, Sorin?
Sorin?
We need milk!
All the cows dead?
My god, this is the longest fucking hallway of my life.
Hello?
I like how I can't even run.
I just have to walk through this.
Oh, there's a bedroom there!
Wait, there's a little hole.
What's in there?
Hello?
It didn't matter if I followed Ellingard or Magnus.
It literally didn't matter.
I just fall in a hole anyway.
Oh, wait.
Show yourself!
Ivor?
I found the Order!
It's over for you!
Okay, let me just tell him his entire plan.
Who the fuck said Ivor is kinda hot?
Are you like Rasputin core?
Stop right there, criminal scum!
Stop right there, Ivor!
Gabriel!
You're alive!
Against all your best efforts, Ivor.
Look at what you've done.
I never dreamt that even you could be this twisted.
Save your posturing, Gabriel.
We both knew your words have always been hollow.
I wrote this game.
You're not going anywhere anymore.
At least not in one piece.
The threats pass harmlessly through me.
Fight!
Don't say anything!
I wanna know more!
Oh my god, I should've said something.
Don't worry!
I've got you!
I did it.
Fight him!
Gabriel, fight him!
Turn him, too!
Nice.
The one time I actually do my job.
Yeah.
This could have all been avoided.
If you wanna stop me, you'll have to catch me first.
Again?
Just swing it!
He's using a potion of swiftness.
Oh, he's fast.
I thought he was invisible.
I'm like the wind!
Oh my god, I wish that worked for me.
Oh shit, no, Gabriel!
Oh my god, I should've tanked it.
Guys, see?
I told you!
I should've tanked it!
Don't worry!
I've got you, Gabriel!
It's gonna happen.
He's getting tired!
He's on!
Swing!
Don't let him leave.
We'll just guard the door and start swinging.
Just keep swinging.
Oh, fuck!
Just stand down.
This one's on you, you puffed up fool!
No, Gabriel!
We won't let you die now!
There's no time for this.
Can't let him die now.
Jesse, Gabriel!
Even more of you?
Will this parade of useless babblers never cease?
What's going on?
See, guys?
I can play the game too.
What?
Oh shit!
Wait, but he like splashed it in front of himself too!
But they are mistaken.
And it will cost them their lives.
Oh no, we're stuck.
Wait, that was episode 2?!
That was such a short episode!
Oh no, we've been slow-mo'd!
What?
That was such a fast one!
I didn't expect it!
My last taco.
I'm tempted to get my ice cream too.
I might as well, it's like a movie.
Is there any way to cure Gabriel's wither sickness?
Would they find a way to defeat the wither storm?
Or would they remain trapped as it continues its ravenous rampage across the entire world?
Or would you die in a hotel?
Alright, so we have two episodes left.
I don't know if he dies or not.
I mean, he has the wither sickness.
So I'm like, how fast does the wither sickness actually work at?
Oh hey, me and my doom yaoi.
Oh,
it's 5?
Okay.
Every
challenge...
Lucas!
And every failure...
There is a gift.
Wait, what is story arc?
It's almost like, what's doom yaoi?
It's yaoi that's doom.
We find new ones in our heroes.
When we're given grief, we find a way to give it back.
What does it mean by this arc is war?
What does that mean?
Why does the sound suddenly went so loud?
They will bring together the bravest and the brightest to stop it.
But finding the last and most elusive member of the Order of the Stone...
Yeah, I was like, why did it get louder?
Would prove their most perilous mission yet.
For some would rather our hero's story end here.
Shutting the door on their adventure forever.
But like all doors, when one closes, another is bound to open.
What's gonna happen?
No!
Stop him!
He's just walking away slowly!
Come back and fight!
Coward!
That was not... that was a short potion.
Good.
Everyone okay?
So what happened to Elengard and Magnus?
We need to find Sorin.
No, look.
He beat you.
No, I think the one won!
That's how I beat him.
Hahaha.
It's okay, the bro code.
He's just- he looks at my- he's looking at my eyes and he understood everything.
Let's keep this between us, don't worry.
It'll be a surprise for- it'll be a nice little surprise for everybody.
Don't be like, surprise!
He's dying!
It's like a little gift.
Everybody, fun little surprise.
He agreed!
Happy birthday, surprise!
Surprise, he's fucking dead.
Is he yelling for Elengard?
He doesn't know when he turns.
Hahaha, we don't need them.
Oh, burn the books!
Oh, wait, what?
We need to burn the books.
I thought it was a cool idea.
His bookcase.
Haha, you wanna get sucked?
Let's doom this.
Let's doom it even more.
Haha, stop flirting!
Okay.
Right below us.
So what?
What?
Okay, we have a better plan exactly.
Yeah, that's right, Lucas!
You don't have a better plan, so we're brute-forcing this.
Just dig down.
Haha, just dig down.
What's the worst that could happen when we dig down?
Wait,
that's not... that's not stone.
That's brick.
Jump down.
Yeah, we couldn't do that to the bookshelf?
Well, you're right.
Why can't we just punch the bookshelf?
It's just bats.
You hear that?
Jump down.
Oh, I should've said dot dot dot, and then let her jump down and experience the bats.
Get away!
Get away, bats!
Leave!
It's okay.
I didn't get bit by a bat, so I won't get rabies.
Anyway, let's see if I can drink water right now.
It's okay, his tummy hurts.
Yeah, he just slipped, guys.
What's that smell?
That's not the scientific... that's not even the scientific word.
The scientific word is feces.
It's okay, guys.
It's not... the surprise isn't ready yet.
We're not close to the surprise.
Okay, we go this way.
Oh, we're in the mineshaft, are we?
Oh, he has a secret town?
No, we have to find Sorin.
Why?
Yeah, why are you scared?
A grinder?
Oh!
Oh my god, he has a mob farmer!
Yeah!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, imagine the XP, guys!
I could be so strong right now.
Oh, that's why it's so dark.
Bro knows the tech.
Yeah.
Okay, he definitely can't handle this.
Explode.
I'm gonna explode!
Okay, wait, what do I...
Oh shit!
I did it!
Look, I did it!
Guys, I did it!
That's so smart.
It worked!
Did it not work?
All part of the plan.
Oh no.
Wait, I don't need it anymore after I find Sorin.
Jumping is easy.
Yeah, I've done so many jumps.
Oh my god, look at Gabriel!
Wait, we're destroying his mob farmer!
Oh my god, we're assholes!
Oh, that's cool.
Wait, that's cool.
Oh my god, there's poison spiders too.
Yeah, stop breaking his mob!
He spent...
He spent 10 days on this, guys.
Oh my god, we're the true griefers.
We're actually griefing his mob farm.
Oh right, I'm the king of Boomtown.
Guys, I've made mob farms before.
That shit is not fun.
And he definitely did it in adventure mode.
He did not do it in creative.
It is not fun.
Watch out!
Oh shit.
Wait, would I get hit if I did that?
I'm gonna get hit here.
Hey bonehead, I'm talking to you!
Any time now, Jesse!
Or survival.
Sorry, he did it in survival mode.
Wait, what?
Yeah, sorry, but he did that in survival mode.
That's not fun.
Don't just stand there, let's go!
It's very time consuming.
I don't know why I thought adventure.
Adventure just seems more...
Just seems cooler.
What if I get poisoned?
Yeah, I wanted to see what it's like if I just got bit by a poison.
So I can match with Gabriel.
I was like, what if I just get bit and just become Spider-Man?
Hold on!
No way!
We got this!
Reuben, wait up!
Imagine doing their 3D choreo for the 3D tracking for Minecraft story mode.
What if Gabriel just dies in the intro?
I knew Gabriel's got this, guys!
That's why I didn't come save him.
I wanted to see Gabriel swing his sword.
Oh shit, no, Reuben!
So cool.
Oops, sorry.
Dooming it even more.
Oh no, no!
We can't mob farm the amulet, it doesn't give levels!
Save amulet.
You don't understand!
This is much more important!
No hesitation.
Hesitation.
I'm here to save the world, not save friends.
Joking, friends are the world.
Oh see, they're 5.
Don't worry, I got you!
Oh shit, wait.
Who's gonna save me?
What happened?
Do I get grinded?
Oh shit, I was curious!
I was curious if like, I just get grinded or not.
Don't worry, I'll make the right choice this time.
Don't worry, guys.
I'll make the right choice.
I thought it was the intro, I didn't miss!
Save the amulet, cause that was always the right choice.
Cause my first choice was the right choice.
It's okay.
How was I supposed to know you can die in the intro?
Okay, nice.
Don't worry, guys!
I can save you again!
These spiders are so tiny.
Where are all these mob spawners coming from?
Okay, now that I know that you can die, die in the intro, let me get a rocket jump real quick.
Oh my god!
And there was slime technology?
Oh my god.
That's too far.
That's too far, guys.
This is where I draw the line.
Oh my god.
No, the trappers!
Oh my god, this shit is crazy.
This is a lag machine right there.
This is like...
God, this is a bannable offense in my Minecraft server.
Everyone's gotta be close.
What?
Are we getting crazier with wither sickness?
I'll keep that in mind.
You're so right.
I'm not!
I'll keep that in mind.
Don't worry.
Guys, I'm just appeasing the old man before he dies.
Guys.
I need to make sure he thinks that I'm with him before he dies.
So then he, you know, he dies happy.
You're not gonna tell your grandpa that he's been wrong this entire time just as about he's dying.
Don't touch my pig!
Yeah,
he's a pig.
You have got to be kidding me.
Okay, Ruben will understand.
He'll understand.
I'll give him treats later.
What the fuck?
Oh, yeah, because the mom timer doesn't work anymore.
The mom timer is really out and he stays tuned.
He's pouring mom fire.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Oh, shit.
I don't got you.
I pressed W.
Am I dead?
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Whoops.
I accidentally pressed W.
Sorry.
Okay, I got this.
My mis-input.
The W was next to the E, guys.
Oh, my ice cream.
Okay, we got this!
At this point, Duke has already become a masochist.
Thank you for the super chat, Fenrir.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I got this.
Okay, I won't die this time.
How do I have like one spider fight and then it was over for me?
How is that possible?
Did I only have one heart?
Got you.
Get out of here!
There's two things I hate.
It's running and monsters.
Yeah!
Wait, what?
What?
Sorry?
Oh, Gabriel!
It's okay!
I got you!
You're not dying yet!
I need you to die in front of our friends!
Remember about the surprise!
I need you to be there for the surprise!
I like the whoop sound effect.
You gotta turn in front of them, dude!
Remember the deal!
You said we gotta keep it a surprise!
Jesus, he does not look okay.
How did they not know?
Are you hurt?
Don't worry, I'm giving him the hot and cold.
I said, are you hurt?
Don't look at him!
Don't look, guys.
Don't look.
Just don't look at them.
Yeah, wait, he did!
He said look!
He has batteries?
Oh, okay.
I was like, did it run out of batteries?
At least we're alive.
Lucas, stop fucking whining!
I'm a bit of a bitch.
At least most of us are alive.
What?
Oh, there he is!
Where's he going?
Yeah.
The legendary amulet runs on two AAA batteries.
It's gonna be like, what the fuck?
Do we need to find batteries now?
What?
Great, we'll follow you.
Yeah, go, Gabriel!
I believe in you, Gabriel.
Okay, I'll follow you, Lucas.
Just put him in the front line!
Just don't look.
Of course!
Hot and cold.
That's how all the doomed ship goes.
Wait, this goes back to the overworld.
Okay, up I go.
Thanks for being the meat shield, Lucas.
I don't understand why that's gameplay.
Like, just go... You walk in one direction and... Like, I could've just had that as a cutscene.
I did not have to walk there.
There was nowhere else to go.
You okay?
You need a hand?
Oh my god, is he gonna fall off the cliff?
Surprise!
Does anyone have any food?
A ladder is just a vertical stair.
Wait, me?
I mean, it's not that long.
Alright, opening the trapdoor.
Hello?
What the fuck is this?
Well, Jim Carrey...
He created his...
It's beautiful!
The Truman Show.
Yeah, what the fuck is this Jim Carrey Truman Show that I'm watching?
You know like those Minecraft shorts where they recreate the Truman Show on the Minecraft shorts on YouTube?
That's exactly what they do.
It's like...
You know, it's like that line where if I don't see it then...
I look at it.
He's building his own Truman Show!
Probably...
Hey, maybe he's...
It's so pretty cool!
It's a padded room.
Why are you being like this?
Are you okay?
Bro, you wanna talk about it, bro?
What?
Oh, Sorensen's Oshie!
Never meet your heroes!
Never meet your heroes.
Flint and steel.
Let's just burn it down.
He just needs space.
That's the winter sickness dying.
He's allergic to wool.
We'll group together and find a way out.
Are you okay?
How are you feeling?
Wait, why would he build this?
Yeah.
So...
What?
How are you feeling, by the way?
You definitely look so healthy.
God, no!
Yeah, other than that.
So where did Soren go?
I guess I'm gonna keep looking around.
I don't think he's, like, okay mentally right now.
He's definitely... His brain's definitely incredibly... Why is he mad?
What did I do, Ruben?
I did not save you and, like, call you just a pig.
What did I do to you?
Okay.
Where is...
Okay, let's... Actually, before... Let me talk to the others first.
Hello.
Hey, guys.
You guys okay?
This is literally, like, the Truman shorts for Minecraft.
Spotter and Lucas.
Yeah.
By the way, Dad's at the babysitter today and tomorrow.
He was so happy.
Like, he saw me put, like...
Because I have a special bag.
Like, I would put... Whenever I put his dog food in the special bag, he freaks out because he knows it's dog sitter time.
Like, he, like, knows it's dog sitter time when I put his dog food... Like, his dog food bin in the bag.
And he was, like, whining in the elevator.
He was actually, like, whimpering in the elevator because he was so excited to see the dog sitter.
Did you find anything?
Did you press it?
How do you know?
Did you press the button?
That's okay.
I've accepted the fact.
I accepted it.
It'll always be you.
Oh my gosh, they made a wolf zombie.
Lucas, are you okay?
Gabriel's worried about you.
Listen, I know I've been prickly, okay?
But...
Dad loves a dog sitter until he takes it out on Ruben.
Thank you for the super chat, Deadpool.
Thank you, thank you.
I mean, you have to have noticed.
The lack of energy, the labored breathing...
What are you saying?
What could it be?
What exactly are you saying, Lucas?
Yeah, Lucas.
What could it be?
There's something wrong.
Okay?
Something big.
It's not fooling anybody.
At least not me.
No way.
That's none of your business.
You're just a ma- What if I don't say anything?
I don't know.
Okay, so I tell you what's bothering me and now you have nothing to say about it?
Oh, I'm doing it!
I didn't mean that!
What do you want?
I keep it together.
Lucas, no matter how upset you get, you've got to keep it together.
No, it's gonna forever be doomed!
What's your problem, Lucas?
You know what?
Never mind.
No!
It was cold when I should have went hot!
No, that's not made of metal.
There must be all sorts of hidden water systems in this place.
Now there's consequence- Oh no, now Reuben angry.
Reuben, no, I'm sorry!
I didn't mean to doom it!
I'm sorry!
I didn't know!
I thought if I say nothing and not acknowledge that I know that things will be okay.
It's cute, I guess.
Oh no, Reuben!
Reuben, no, I'm sorry!
I did not mean to doom it!
That's cute.
Oh no, Reuben, talk to me, Reuben!
Okay, Reuben knows I fucked up.
I gotta live with my actions, guys.
I wanted to keep the surprise!
I keep my promises, Gabriel!
I thought if I say nothing, then like, you know...
Then like I don't acknowledge that I'm lying.
Reuben knows my sins.
No, it's okay.
We'll just be doomed.
I can fix it.
Guys, it's okay.
We can fix it.
There's still a way to fix the relationship, guys.
We can still fix it.
Guys, we can fix it!
You might be wondering how I got into this scenario.
We can fix it, guys!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I just gotta go all- I just gotta go all out.
It'll be fine.
Just gotta give Lucas lots of attention.
It's fixable.
Guys, I can fix it!
I can fix this relationship!
It's okay, Lucas!
Lucas, I need you to move.
Lucas, I can't- Lucas, move!
Alright,
there we go.
That wasn't too hard, was it?
It's okay.
It's like enemies to lovers, guys.
It's the...
It's the trope.
It's the classic trope, guys.
Ooh, look at that tension between me and him now.
Look at that.
Look at all that tension we have!
And I'll fix it.
This will make us stronger in the end.
Look at the vision!
See the vision!
I see the vision.
It's okay, we're almost at the surprise.
It's okay.
I'm just happy you're here, buddy.
Wait, don't apologize.
You're just old.
And dying, true.
Yeah.
This is enemies to friends to enemies again.
You forgot the loving part!
Nexy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can fix it!
I just need to talk to him!
It's okay.
It's fixable.
It's fixable, guys.
It's so fixable.
Oh my god, what a builder.
Is he lonely?
I think that guy... I think Sorin is just really lonely.
Oh, the music's coming from here.
Is Olivia not going to talk to me?
Hello?
What the fuck?
That's him!
Sorin!
No, that's just a recording.
What the...
Yeah.
Yeah, it didn't play itself.
Something played it.
I guess he really likes the sound of his own voice, then.
What?
Oh, he's dressed up as an Enderman!
He's observing the Enderman like those, like, nature documentaries.
Where they dress up like penguins.
They just find a shorter guy.
Why would he want to?
Yeah.
He's an imposter among them.
Wait, what?
Okay, now he's definitely crazy.
Where are these?
Did I just steal it?
What the fuck?
Okay, he's definitely crazy.
Okay.
What the fuck?
That's a love... Oh, he fucked an Enderman!
Yeah,
he's got... No, he's definitely banged an Enderman.
He literally said, that's a love song!
Okay, put it on.
I shall become one of them.
That's right.
Oh, and it's in all black.
Kinky!
Just like American Horror Story all over again.
Oh, wait, why Stinky?
Wait...
Wait a minute...
What is Soren doing?
Wait, what's it for?
Oh, he's teaching the Enderman how to craft!
Wait, but what happens if I look at the Enderman?
Yeah, why does he have two?
And why is one taller than the other?
Next scene, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The Enderman...
Percy, what will she do?
I don't even own this!
It's not even mine!
I'm just trying to do my job!
Ruben, smell.
What do you smell with your nose?
I guess he can't smell over here.
Wait, what's up top though?
Time up.
Is there anything important up here?
No, just books.
What's up here?
There has to be something important, right?
Oh, there's like crafting there.
But like, does it work?
Like the... if I look at them through this?
Oh, I have to pick up clay blocks!
Okay, I need four.
Okay, now I know.
I just have to grab clay blocks.
Okay, there's like one more downstairs.
Wait, he was there?
Wait, he was?
Oh my god, I didn't see.
I was looking at...
Wait, I thought they all looked the same.
Where is he?
Oh, I see him!
I see him!
He's just standing there, fucking freak!
Oh my god, I saw him!
Fucking freak!
Freak!
Get away from those Endermen!
I saw him.
Get your hands away from those Endermen!
I wonder if there's any in the furnace.
Oh no, it's just Olivia.
I'm missing... oh, there's another one.
Oh, there's one back there in the brewing stand.
Okay.
Why you need to make two, you freak?
Why do you have two?
There are no rules against the Endermen.
Alright.
I'll be smart.
Just find the one that literally looks like him.
Oh, I get it.
I'll craft and then he'll be like, I did it!
I knew I could make them smart.
There's no laws against the Endermen, Gabriel.
Batman, there's no laws against the Endermen, Gabriel.
Zylo, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Joker, stop.
Stop, Joker.
Wait, what?
I won't take a boy.
Give me your block.
Give it to me.
It's mine.
My block.
That's right.
But it's just that easy.
Oh, I don't think he happy.
Oh, he's definitely not happy.
Wait, I'll show you where he is.
He's like right over there.
Wait, they're dancing.
Joker, stop.
He's like... Wait, where is he?
He's like... Wait, where did he go?
I saw him out that window.
No, it'll be fine.
Oh, he's still jumping around.
He's like... Where'd my block go?
Wait, where is he?
I swear, he was like next to the crafter.
It's fine.
I remember how to build it.
Okay, two, four, five, six.
Okay.
I remember this.
Oh my god, he's gonna be like... I did it.
I taught him how.
I taught them how to build.
Wait, no.
Wait, what?
Yeah, remove this.
Yeah, I was gonna say, why did it place it there?
You think he's looking?
Okay, I'll do like all that and I wanna see if he's looking.
Do you think he was watching?
Where is he?
I can't find him.
No, I know.
I just wanna see if... I just wanna see if I can find him.
He's gonna be so proud.
What?
Oh yeah, he definitely looks like he abandoned Iron Man.
Poor dude.
Yeah.
Yeah, you upset in his hair.
What do you need me for?
Even so, what do you need me for?
I've gone out of my way to avoid these types of problems.
We have to save the world.
I don't even remember what it looks like up there.
Help me save the world.
How?
The Formida Bomb.
The F-bomb.
He's like, but my lovers...
They need me.
I can't leave them.
You don't need me.
You need my stuff.
I found that when you give people what they want, they turn on you.
They become resentful.
Has someone done that before?
Yeah, who doesn't?
All of them!
It's why I prefer Endermen.
They always do what you expect, almost to a fault.
You're a stranger.
And what you're asking for is too dangerous.
I have the amulet.
What?
Gabriel gave it to me.
Gabriel asked me to reassemble the Order of the Stone.
The Order of the Stone?
They asked for me?
I always knew they needed me, but I was never sure if they wanted me.
It's lonely down here without your friends.
Eligard is your friend.
Hmm, I don't know.
Does she ever talk about me?
Uh, sure.
What kinds of things do they say?
Oh no.
Give me an example.
They've missed you?
That you were missed.
Really?
Maybe it was more missing.
You have to read between the lines.
Yes, yes you do.
But what about you?
Are you my friend?
As long as we're on the subject.
Not to put you on the spot.
Sure, we can be friends!
That's the best thing I've heard in years.
Oh no.
Admittedly, it's not a very high bar.
Oh, that's so sad, Sorin.
Don't worry, I'm going to help you.
Because that's what friends do.
Before we leave, I'm going to give my old friends a gift.
Oh no, now I'm committed to a situationship with an Enderman fucker.
Gary may seem scary, but he's a swell guy.
Sally dilly-dallies, give her credit she tries.
They might look the same to the untrained eye.
That was too easy.
But that's a lie.
Alright, let it out!
Wait, is that?
Are you?
He's like, yeah!
Sorin!
Whoa.
Oh my god, he touched my arm.
You look terrible.
Terribly handsome?
Hello, old friend.
We've been looking for you.
Wait, Gabriel and Sorin are friends?
Oh, I should have said Gabriel.
Wait, how did he get in?
Who looked at him?
What did I do?
How did I alter his behavior?
They didn't like that Sorin cheated.
I took his block.
It was his favorite block.
We break the fountain.
Oh, the fountain, yeah!
They're scared of water.
I'm so smart.
What do you mean Sorin is such?
I fucking...
I came up with the plan!
Exactly, why didn't we make the house two blocks tall?
It wouldn't hurt me, cause like...
I have my suit on.
I can look at him.
Thanks, Sorin.
My new best friend.
Okay, let's break this.
No, why?
Oh, we have to break the other one.
It's okay, we got this.
I can do it again.
Watch this.
I'm fucking Ruben.
He's like, bath time.
Bath time.
What if I just look at him?
Hey guys.
So what does Sorin do to you guys?
Like, actually.
Alright.
Time to break the fountain.
Did that work?
Oh there, it did it.
I was using the claws of the Enderman.
That was taught to me by Sorin.
See, it worked.
I told you guys it works.
What's the hold up?
There's more?
Just don't look.
They're in the Truman Show.
Oh my god, look at all these background actors we hired.
The fuck?
Oh what?
Okay.
It's like a conga line.
Jesus Christ, that is so fucking scary.
Like, they're all just waiting for us over there.
Conga-ing.
They're like...
You took my block.
I take your life.
Are you my block taker?
They want to join the conga line.
What?
Quick!
Break the bridge!
Okay, yeah guys, thanks for helping out everyone.
I really appreciate it.
Oh, it's a sprinkler!
Let's instill!
He didn't want a conga.
Wait, my flint and steel.
What's the point of carrying a lighter if I can't use it?
Oh look, they're dancing.
Oh shit, that's a lot.
They're dancing.
Dance Enderman, dance!
Don't worry, I'm doing it.
Wait, can I drown?
No, I don't want to do this all over again if I do drown.
We're not gonna force drowning, guys.
I don't want to do this all over again.
We're not.
No, this seems like if I drown, I have to do it a long time.
Gabriel, Gabriel, no!
Gabriel, you're dying in front of the team, Gabriel!
I'm not letting you die in front of me alone!
It has to be in front of everybody.
Just like how Lee would have wanted.
Maximum shock factor, exactly.
Maximum surprise.
Because I promised him a surprise and we're getting it.
Oh shit, they're all here.
By the way, we broke your mob farmer, Soren.
This is how you're gonna find out.
Don't worry, watch this.
Nevermind.
Okay.
Oh shit.
What?
You had 20 years!
Do it!
Holy shit!
Wait, that's cool.
That's actually cool.
Holy shit!
You came to the wrong neighborhood.
Good!
Pass it.
Don't ask questions you don't want to know the answers to.
What?
Oh, he wants to portal up.
Okay guys, we can piss him off, guys.
Guys, we can't.
He's... Guys, you don't understand.
I saw him.
I think he fucks Enderman, guys.
I... He can... I think he has like no boundaries, guys.
We cannot piss Soren off.
Oh shit.
There's a... He has no boundaries, guys.
I don't want to piss him off.
He's capable of anything.
Yeah, he'll do anything at this point.
Wait, what?
Haha.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're gonna save this, guys.
It's fixable.
Guys, it's fixable.
But he knows.
He knows about the sickness.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah, I totally did.
Look at that, guys.
See, I'm fixing it.
I agreed.
I did it, guys.
I agreed with him.
Hey, Reuben.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Okay, wait.
Does Olivia want to talk?
Wait, where's Olivia?
Oh, there's Olivia.
Just take everything.
Doesn't hurt.
Just take it all.
Okay, now I'll press the lever.
I just need to press the button, right?
Jesus Christ, what sort of system does he have?
Alright.
I'm ready.
Oh, there's the minecart.
Okay, that is not how redstone works, but okay.
Yeah.
Your new best friend.
Let's build...
Let's do it.
Yeah, what's the recipe?
Huh?
Oh, so we have to build them?
We have to build it while we're on the witherstorm.
That's just a TNT with a fancy resource.
We destroy the...
Yeah.
Oh.
To the minecarts, everyone!
Things will be fine, right?
See, they don't know.
They already forgot that, you know, we took their blocks.
Because there's... What the fuck?
Oh, he knows the sins you've committed, Soren.
The endermen are like, we know what you did.
You know who you are.
Where they left?
What?
Wait.
See,
you guys looked there together.
I knew it.
Oh, shit.
What?
My hands are off the keyboard.
I thought we were still watching.
Oh, the witherstorm.
It's time.
Soren?
Oh.
No, the horses!
Someone free the horses!
Gabriel!
Alright.
I shall be a hero.
They shall write stories about me.
And it won't be written out just like Igor.
Or Eva.
Wait, what's his name again?
I already forgot his name.
Igor.
Oh my god, I finally have armor.
No, I'm taking the fucking...
I'm taking the fucking TNT armor.
If I'm handling TNT, why the fuck would I take an engineer armor?
Yeah, take the... why would I take the armor?
I'm going to have to set down a crafting table out there and make that formidable.
Everyone else, grab a buddy and split up.
We need to keep that witherstorm on track.
So build, build, build.
You see?
Don't forget, super TNT in the middle.
And gunpowder all around.
No one tell her.
Okay, I'll have TNT resistance now.
That's right, I'm gonna be a hero.
Woo!
I
hope this works.
What the fuck?
Oh.
This and then...
All the TNT powder around it.
Oh my god.
It's going crazy.
Don't worry, I've got it.
I'm swimming.
If he's gonna eat me.
He's gonna eat a bomb.
Okay, I got it.
Mid-air crafting.
Oh shit.
Okay, he still has hearts, guys.
Still has hearts.
Guys.
Guys, he didn't poop into air.
He's okay.
He's fine, he didn't poop.
He didn't poop!
No way!
Oh my god, the F-bomb.
Oh my god, wait, it's a command block.
Take it.
Oh.
See, look, he's not there.
He's just sleeping, guys.
He's just sleeping.
Oh shit.
I saw green and I thought that was him, but I realized it was Axel.
Wait, did we do it?
Are we heroes?
Did we beat him?
Wait, where's Magnus?
I couldn't have done it without you, Lucas.
Oh, all of us.
Okay, I was just trying to compliment Lucas.
Guys, where's Magnus?
Guys, where is he?
Wait.
Oh no.
Magnus?
Give him- someone give him a golden apple, quick!
Magnus!
Magnus, no!
I'm so sad.
Can we have five booms, please?
No!
Please!
Someone give him some apples!
Someone feed him!
Wait, what does he mean by that?
Oh, were these all the people trapped inside?
Long live the boom.
Thank you, the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I'll save them all.
I'm not leaving you.
That was the best sound.
What was that sound effect?
No!
Sorry, the sound effect.
The thud sound effect.
When I said, doom the yaoi, I didn't think that would be it!
It was doomed all along!
I can't believe it.
We did it, Patrick!
We did it!
Save the city!
X-Heroes, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
No!
The yaoi!
I can't believe it!
We lost the best character!
Patrick!
Don't worry, I'm a hero now.
Wait, just rip it out.
What is going on?
Huh?
No, I wanna be absorbed.
Let me be absorbed.
Be one with the block.
Oh shit, okay, nevermind.
Hey, you're alive?
I wanna be one with the block.
Huh?
Wait, what?
This died for no reason?
Oh no, we separated them.
That's even worse.
Wait, she's sick?
Oh, she doesn't remember.
Oh man.
She got way too sick.
Oh no, we separated all of them.
Where's my army?
Where the fuck is my army?
I died for it.
Untangle bitter rivalries.
And find the strength to make one last stand against the storm.
Oh my god.
How many episodes?
We have two more, right?
Okay, episode four is incredibly long from what I've heard, right guys?
We have episode four.
Episode five.
Episode six?
Episode seven?
Wait, I thought...
Wait, what?
Oh, for this story arc.
Oh!
Okay, okay, I got a little confused.
So how long...
How long is episode four?
How long is this last one?
What is a story...what is...
Episode four is eight hours long?!
Oh, two hours, okay.
Okay, I was gonna say...
Okay, it's two hours.
Guys, alright, do you think...
Guys, do we finish it?
Do we finish it, guys?
Do we finish it?
I was gonna freak out if I was gonna...
I was gonna be like, guys, I don't know if I'm strong enough for that.
I don't know.
For Magnus?
Okay, we'll do it for Magnus, guys.
Alright, for Magnus.
We finish the arc.
Okay, let me grab some ice cream then.
If we're gonna finish this, I need some ice cream.
I'll be right back.
Yeah, my voice is okay.
I just wanna get ice cream then.
We're gonna finish it.
Yeah, I have tonado!
I have the dark...
Oh, I should've seen that!
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you, thank you!
Is it for the V-card thing?
I heard about that.
Grace, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
We have to keep going.
I'm invested in this story now!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Eleanor Rice, thank you for the super chat!
Basically, it's like...
He's pulling V-cards.
And like, if he gets any of the cards...
I think it was like, any of the best cards...
The level 3... I don't know the term.
The level 3 cards, then he's going over there to chat and give subs.
So I assume he got one of mine.
Thank you!
I'm playing Minecraft story mode right now.
Alright, the last episode.
I can't believe Magnus is dead.
I can't believe it!
This is the last episode.
I just... I was thinking about 5 gifted ships!
Thank you, thank you!
Yeah, the trading cards.
Like, he died for nothing!
And then we turned it into 3 withers!
She should've let me get absorbed by the wither.
If she let me get absorbed by the command block...
I could've been like, slash exit.
Slash delete or some shit.
Or slash kick all.
I have the... what's that Italian ice cream called that's like vanilla with like the little chocolate bits in there?
Or gelato?
Oh no!
Nah, stretchatella!
I got that.
I love gelato.
I can't believe we just basically made him stronger.
Slash jump at you!
I could've done that!
The thing's not dead!
Oh wait, she doesn't know I didn't pick her!
We're saved!
We're coming!
She doesn't know!
We just need Gabriel to die.
Omni, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, trade!
Big trade!
She wouldn't know.
I did it!
Look out!
Oh shit!
What?
What are the endermen doing?
They'll be killed!
Sorry, I can't stand by and watch.
I'd be condemning them to death!
He's like, my ways!
These endermen are running directly into danger!
My ways!
You're putting us in danger every second you just stand there!
No!
The harem!
Let's build a portal!
Do we have...
Do we have the materials?
Does anyone have obsidian?
One of the hardest materials to get right now!
It's okay, they're already tamed.
We should be fine.
Slow down, horse!
Yeah, yeah, let me on you!
Wait, what about us?
Come on, Jesse, we got this!
Leave them!
We'll take the reins, and they can just hang on!
I'll take Gabriel!
Then I've got Petra!
I don't know about you, but she has red eyes right now!
She's like, closer to turning than Gabriel!
I feel like she's gonna bite Lucas at any moment!
I'm just gonna take Gabriel!
Bro, she has red eyes!
She is not!
She is fucking turning!
I am not risking that!
Slap!
Whoa!
Oh my god, he's on a spider!
She's fine!
I'm gonna slap this one!
Slap!
I'm going to all of them just to slap them!
Chicken Jockey!
Get absorbed!
I'm making sure the other mobs get absorbed!
Alright, jump!
That's right!
I made sure to slap all of these!
Don't worry, are there any other mobs?
Oh?
His people need him!
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
Oh no!
Sorry!
I was looking at the Endermen and eating my ice cream!
Okay, nice.
I don't want to redo that.
I had to dodge it all.
I felt like the game was definitely going to punish me if I died.
Oh?
What the fuck?
Not mine!
What?
Build a bridge.
It does not have to be that wide!
Why does it have to be that wide?
Why did Lucas build a front side of the bridge?
Was that Sorin or Lucas?
Was that Sorin that built the decoration?
He's just like, it's got to look pretty.
It's aesthetic.
He's like, you don't understand, it's got to look beautiful.
I don't know.
Professionals have standards!
You don't even know who you are!
A storm did something.
A storm did something to her.
So, she doesn't remember anything?
Not even me?
Who can forget me?
Jesse, this is awful.
You, Jesse, you're the one who rescued me.
Tell me, please.
Yeah, it's me.
I've always rescued you.
All I remember was endless blackness.
And then, you were there.
I thought we lost you.
I tried so hard to save you.
I thought I was, too.
All I know is, I was so scared in there.
I thought for sure I was dying.
Well, you didn't.
You made it back alive.
We didn't all make it back, though.
Oh, man.
Magnus.
Sadly, he died for nothing.
Are we talking about Magnus?
Like, what was the point?
Oh, Magnus.
I let her live?
But Magnus was the cooler one.
He gave me five boons.
He wants us to fight.
It's not my fault.
It's never my fault, guys.
No, it wasn't my fault!
Being emotional is getting us nowhere!
What I want to know is, what happened out there today?
He volunteered his armor!
My instructions were simple.
You were the one in the middle of everything.
What went wrong?
We made it worse.
Yeah, he got stronger.
He became three.
The computer block is still out there, Soren.
Blast!
And now, to make matters worse, we've gone from one weatherstorm to three!
Our plan was a total failure!
Our plan?
We cast the foul thing into the abyss.
Why didn't I destroy that cursed block ages ago?
So, is the command block controlling all three weatherstorms?
Why are you asking me?
You're the master of building!
Am I expected to know every last thing in the universe?
I need a moment to think.
If we don't ask you, who do we ask?
Is he always like this?
Oh, I'm his best friend.
Good idea.
Oh, it's his group!
Maybe your friends survived.
It's time!
We're fixing it, guys!
We're fixing it!
I did it!
I'm gonna talk to Lucas.
We gotta fix this.
Lucas, don't worry.
I'll do everything I can to save your friends with you.
I told you.
I'm going after my friends.
I thought the other ocelots were dead.
But if they're not, I need to go find them.
Oh, wait.
Look, I am grateful to you guys for bringing me this far.
But I can't leave them alone out there.
Not with three weatherstorms raging.
You can't just up and leave, Lucas.
You're part of our team.
Yeah, we need you!
And you saying that just reminds me that I left my team.
But, Lucas...
Look, you and me, we've made a pretty good team so far.
Look at that!
I fixed it!
We can call us friends.
Guys!
He called me his friend.
Wait.
We are helping them.
Please stay.
No!
I couldn't!
I couldn't press it in time!
Lucas!
Come back!
Oh my god!
I dot, dot, dotted him!
Lucas!
I was like, oh my god!
We need you!
Oh my god!
Lucas, come back!
Ruben, I fucked up!
I fucked up, Ruben!
Hey, buddy.
You doing okay?
Of course you are.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I had to press what!
I dot, dot, dotted!
Oh my god!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's my comedic relief.
Oh, she always punished.
Oh my god!
You have Lucas's eyes!
You're my new Lucas.
You have his eyes!
Oh my god.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The two minutes, yeah, is coming from your own keyboard.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, I'm such a smartass.
Not really.
Okay, he angry.
What the fuck did I do?
I didn't do clearly nothing.
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Now all I'm left with is you guys!
Thank you.
He jumped off?
Yes.
I've never seen a play through of Minecraft story mode as a fumbling boy failure.
Thank you for the super chat, Micro.
Thank you, thank you.
What do we have?
We have Ruben!
With no foreshadowing whatsoever.
Of course you know us.
We are the Order of the Pig.
Oh wait, she wasn't there.
I'm rich, thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
I couldn't save you.
I just couldn't.
I tried.
All that matters is that I tried.
She doesn't have to know.
She doesn't know.
I tried so hard.
Ruben, at least I have you, right?
Okay, hello Gabriel.
Are you feeling better?
It's okay, his eyes aren't red yet, so we still have time.
Lucky bird going after the horse.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, you deserve to rest.
We went so far.
What did they do to him?
How the fuck did they do to Ivor?
We've all made it.
I'm gonna go quiet.
I wanna know what the fuck is going on.
I wanna know the story behind it.
Wait, since Lucas is gone, I'm just gonna go full chaotic mode now.
Now it doesn't matter.
Why am I being nice?
It doesn't matter anymore.
Doesn't matter anymore.
Why be nice?
Oh, we gotta save Ruben.
Ruben, are you okay?
Yeah, Ruben.
It's not my fault she's crazy.
Oh, I helped Gabriel.
I don't wanna lose you.
Yeah, Ruben.
Yeah, I know you've run off before, but things are different now.
We've lost too many people already.
Yeah, Ruben.
After everything that happened...
The order, the world needs us.
Just you and me.
It's okay, Ruben.
After everything that's happened, I know that you and me will never falter.
That you and me are forever.
Sydney, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, why are they arguing?
I wasn't there to instigate.
How are they arguing?
Wait, it's not here?
Oh, it's with Soren.
Okay.
Forever and ever and ever.
Soren, you need to listen to me.
Oh, what good has ever come of that?
Wait, what?
Come to lock me in another room?
I came to offer my help.
He's been following us.
It's not like that.
You need to hear me out.
What you don't understand is you are all in very grave danger.
No, I mean specifically this group.
The weatherstorm isn't acting randomly.
It's following Gabriel.
Gabriel?
You see, I may have programmed it to follow his amulet.
Oh my God, he's slash followed.
You mean the Order's amulet.
Yes, Soren.
That amulet.
And the reason you didn't tell us that ages ago?
I'm not required to tell you anything.
You are when I'm the one he gave the amulet to.
What?
I... I didn't know.
Ivor, you fool.
You've created a monster that's following Jesse, and it's only getting stronger.
You don't think I realize that.
Nothing can stop those things.
Nothing even hurts them.
Well, except Enderman.
Enderman?
Jesse's right.
The wither's gaze passed over them, and they went wild.
If I had been there with my own eyes, we actually just saw a bunch of Enderman pull blocks off a witherstorm.
So, the half of them, working together, might be able to destroy a witherstorm entirely.
It's a promising concept, at least in theory.
Wait, could you coordinate them?
Could you coordinate the Enderman somehow?
Make them attack all at once?
If I know my Enderman, all we'd need to do is get them into the storm's vicinity.
Oh, you definitely know your Enderman.
Don't worry.
I know that.
I do not doubt that, sir.
...an unintended side effect of you flooding the end.
This is just like the old days, Zoran.
You and your crazy ideas.
Hush, Ivor, for once!
You're the one that summoned the wither!
If anything, his crazy ideas is just fucking the Enderman.
Ivor's crazy idea is... wait, we use your fortress.
His crazy idea is literally just fucking summoning a god that's gonna kill everything.
We bring the wither storms to the Enderman.
Just one problem.
You're forgetting about the command block.
The original doomed ally.
It's clear now that no weapon can destroy it.
Not even a Formidable.
Actually, I may have a solution to that.
You see, when I first took possession of the command block...
You mean stole it?
Yes, but we fail safe.
Oh, he got it from...
A backup plan, just in case.
Well, I'd say just in case.
So that's why he's mad.
He stole the item from him.
He used him.
Also, Cookie, welcome to Tomato Farm!
Welcome, welcome!
The power of the command block itself.
Use it to enchant a weapon, and you'll be able to smash the command block to bits.
Forever!
Yes.
Yes, that's it!
It could very well solve all our problems.
What are we waiting for?
Let's go get that book!
Just one problem.
It's at my secret lab, which is...
Oh, you have another secret lab?
How far could it possibly be?
How many secret labs does he have?
It's the farthest place a person can travel before being utterly...
Huh?
Oh dear, what was that?
What?
How did it find us so quickly?
Oh, it's our amulet.
It just keeps coming for us.
We just threw the amulet away.
It's following us.
Punch him!
Wait, what the fuck?
What was that interaction?
What?
He just like...
Malady?
And we're just okay with him now?
Like, he destroyed the whole world?
And...
Wait, why?
Wait...
Okay, you're right.
Here you go, Axel.
He's like, you could be killed.
Okay, here you go, Axel.
I trust you.
I was like, no, don't do it, Axel!
And then she's like, you could be killed.
I was like, okay, you can take it.
Good choice.
Yeah!
Oh,
so they're not okay anymore.
What the fuck?
We need you to take us to your secret lab.
Hey, Jesse.
Let's try our handshake again, just once for the road.
The one where we don't do anything?
You got it.
Oh, we gotta rap?
Oh, well.
Real heroes don't need handshakes.
What?
I'll see you at Sorin's, alright?
Not if I see you first.
Was that a quick time event?
That was a quick time event?
I...
I didn't realize it happened so fast!
I didn't realize!
My hands were off the keyboard!
This is barely a game!
Like, what?
Okay.
This is barely a game!
Why would my hands be on my keyboard when I'm mostly using my mouse?
I still managed to fumble.
Okay, no more.
We won't be failing unless it's funny.
Okay, my hands are on the keyboard and mouse now!
Are you happy?
Oh my god, the original Doom Yowie right there.
Oh my god, it's so far.
His secret lab.
What is he doing?
Is he sleeping on Sorin?
What the fuck is my expression?
Like, he's like, yeah, I chip it.
Alright, my hands are still on the keyboard and mouse, guys.
Yeah, this is definitely very, very far.
Are we there yet?
Oh my god.
Why are we bringing a sick person too with us?
Like, I'm pretty sure...
I'm pretty sure she's, like, way far, even further gone than Gabriel.
Like, her eyes are red.
Gabriel's eyes are not red yet.
Feels like we've been riding forever.
Oh shit.
Far lands?
Yeah, what exactly is it?
Oh shit.
Oh no, we haven't eaten yet.
We can't turn back now.
Wait,
do we not have food in the... Do we not have food at the laboratory?
Do you not stock up any food?
Wait, what the fuck?
I, like, went backwards.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, sorry.
I'm, like, fucking...
It's so hard to control this.
Okay.
Okay, I have to go down instead of... Like, if I go... If I go...
Back... I go backwards when I press W and that makes zero sense.
Oh, there's potato.
I'm gonna eat it first.
Potatoes.
Okay, don't worry guys.
Clearly, I'll find more for the rest, okay?
What if I eat all the potatoes though?
Okay, I'll bring one.
I'll bring one.
Okay.
Okay, I'll bring one.
But, like, what's over there though?
Huh?
Maybe there's food here.
Oh!
Yeah.
Witches hate trespassers.
Besides, there are plenty of potatoes around.
Oh, there's a witch.
We need that cake.
That's okay.
It's not like anybody's gonna die.
We lost Lucas already.
I'm ready for the bad run.
We lost Lucas.
I'm ready for anything.
Nice, that would be good for something in the future.
That's right.
Can't catch me.
Get out of here, witch!
Witch!
Where did Ivor go?
Wait, he lied!
He fucking lied!
Oh, shit!
He has an army!
No, the horses!
Guys, keep going!
Ivor said the Far Lancer just passed the swamp.
Wait, where is Ivor?
I thought he was with you.
He bailed on me.
No, he disappeared outside the witch's house.
Yeah!
He fucking left!
Come on!
Jesus Christ, what the fuck is that range?
Guys, I think we lost him for...
Huh?
Wow!
You lost him for wow?
What?
Wow.
Is that the Far Lands?
It's like we're at the edge of the world.
Actually, we seem to be at the corner of it.
Welcome to the Far Lands, my friend.
Is that a real thing?
It is?
I'm glad Jesse snagged this cake.
Makes the whole wall of insanity thing a lot easier to face.
I think I like cake.
Who doesn't like cake?
Oh, it's an old Minecraft.
What is it?
Yeah.
Very few have seen it in person.
I'm feeling kinda overwhelmed right now.
You're not the only one.
Yeah, how can you live here?
Why would Ivor live here?
I mean, it's one thing to build a wool world inside the End, but this?
Oh, I doubt he lives here.
He most likely comes here only for his most secretive research.
Whatever Ivor is hiding in here, it will be extremely well guarded.
Wait, and then there's like lapis everywhere?
Or is that like he pre-built?
Oh, he must have pre-built that.
Built that in the Far Lands.
Look.
I fucked up, okay?
Not the Axel part.
Like, I didn't want to die.
But...
Is this...
a maze?
What the fuck?
How did he build this with a command block?
Did he go slash creative?
Slash change game mode creative?
Doki dot dot dot.
No, let's do the maze!
Let's do it!
I'm at my chaotic run now.
This is where the two hours is gonna come from.
This is the two hours.
Right here in the maze.
Slash...
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Okay, no.
There's no maze part yet.
It's fine.
See?
We're fine, guys.
Look at that.
Almost out of the maze.
The Far Lands may be perilous, but they are indisputably fascinating.
Stone Wop?
Waterfall?
We should probably keep moving.
Maybe we should go this way, right?
A stone waterfall, huh?
Only in the Far Lands.
Oh, okay.
It's just the same thing.
Guys, looks like this is a...
Oh!
What?
There's too many!
We can't fight them all!
Everyone, back!
I'm gonna leap.
You need to climb when you have a potion of leaping!
Oh, my God.
I knew it!
I told you guys!
Guys, caught in the vines?
Well, that worked, I suppose.
Yeah, I guess.
Okay, it feels like a waste that I did that.
But now what do we do?
We're all separated.
Let's just head that way and find a place where the pads connect.
Sure hope they don't get lost in there.
What about me?
I don't get lost in there.
Yeah, I was gonna say, what about me?
Can I actually fall back down?
No, I can't.
Oh, my God!
I can finally walk a little bit faster!
It really only took me four episodes.
I can finally walk a little bit faster, guys.
Look at me go!
Wait, no, it's not this way.
What the fuck?
Oh, no.
How do I get there?
It's not there.
Maybe here?
Okay, no, that's a dead end.
Oh, no, I'm a little lost now.
A floating land?
Wait, what?
Okay, guys, now I know where the two hours are gonna...
Okay.
Okay, maybe here?
Okay, this... no.
No?
Maybe we go backwards?
And then from here, we can...
Maybe we go even back?
And then we go from here?
It has to be it, right?
Yeah, yeah, and then we go from here, and then...
No, no, no, trust the process!
Guys, trust the process!
And then from here...
See, there's a cutscene!
That means I'm doing the right thing!
Look at that!
We go backwards to go front.
Get out.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, now I don't have a sword.
That's a little bit worrisome.
Okay, we go backwards to go forward, guys.
Guys, no, no, no, trust the process!
You go backwards to go forward, and then we go even more backwards, apparently...
To go forward, guys.
Look at that!
Look at that, guys!
Omni, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
See, look!
They did it!
Wait, what?
Yeah, see?
Look!
Wait, why are they downstairs?
A waffa, strange and eldritch phenomenon.
Ow!
Okay, there we go.
Last shot!
Okay.
Omni, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh.
Wait, why was Olivia at the bottom?
Why would they be at the bottom?
They should be down...downstairs.
Or upstairs.
Okay, and then we go this way.
My god, if only I could run.
At least I'm moderately...briskly walking this time.
We go here.
And then...
And then here.
This has to be it, right?
Is it here?
Wait, is that...
Is that a plane?
Anything in here?
Yeah, there's a flying machine!
Wait,
how do I start the slime ball?
The...the...
The slime...the flying machine.
Wait, where are the rest?
Where is everybody?
Yeah!
Were they together?
They...they were together!
I don't trust this.
I don't think that's her.
There's no way that's her.
Let's find the others.
It's weird that...
I don't know, why were the others gone?
Why were they together?
It's so weird, why were they split up?
I'll figure it out, don't worry.
Cause I'm a genius!
Oh, she's mad.
Hahaha!
I have YouTube, Olivia.
Don't worry.
Wait, she said that?
That's fucked!
Oh my god.
Yeah, prove her...that's actually fucked.
I can't believe she said that to me.
Yeah.
And two of them...one of them is dead and the other one is slowly dying.
They're not so great, are they?
And then, the third one is fucking Enderman.
True, Order of the Fraud.
If great, why die?
And the other guy is just there.
Stop being a doomer!
We won!
We won that building contest!
Yeah!
Yeah, Olivia!
We did that!
We didn't really save the world, we won the building contest!
With that 2D creeper, our greatest victory.
Very hard contest.
I love this, call them immortal cause they're frauds.
I fucking hate the immortal.
Wait a second, I think I see what he was trying to do.
Jesse, take this piston, craft it into a sticky piston, then place it on the other side of the barge along with a redstone block.
You got all that?
No.
I don't think so.
What?
Ruben, what did she...Ruben, what did she say?
Ruben, I don't know.
Ruben, what do I do?
She's gonna be just fine.
Ruben, trust me!
Just need a pep talk.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh,
I did it!
What?
Nice.
I did it.
I don't know how, but I did...
Oh, whoops.
I did it.
Is that it?
What else do I have to make?
Do I have to make anything else?
Oh, redstone block?
Oh, I know how to do that.
There we go.
Yay!
I thought it was block plus red, but then I realized, no, she gave me nine.
Oh, wait.
No.
I thought you would do that for me.
Wait, do I have to do it myself?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Use.
I did it.
Yeah, we did it.
Wait, what did she do?
I don't know.
She just gave me...
She just told me the items to craft and then I put everything together.
See, Olivia?
We're great builders.
Let's go.
We build really well.
Everybody, get on!
Oh, shit.
Flint and steel.
Get on, Jesse!
What if I miss it?
Oh, I shouldn't.
Just watch it fly away.
Turkey fleas.
Dot, dot, dot.
Huh?
The chicken machine.
I was like, that's how we make Gabriel!
Yeah, I kind of remember.
Wait.
It's already fading.
Fading...
Yeah, that's true.
That's how we met him.
Take my advice, Petra.
Some stories are better left forgotten.
That was amazing!
Isn't it amazing?
Tinkering with the Far Lands is nothing to laugh about.
Yeah, this is a serious matter!
Oh, there's like lapis here.
Wait, that means there's an...
Oh, because he has to read it for enchantment.
Alright.
It could be any one of these books.
It could be any one of them.
What about here?
Oh my God.
Twenty-four?
There was not that many potions back then in 2012.
Or whatever year Telltale went bankrupt.
Look.
He had to leave, okay?
I tried everything I could.
I had to.
I did everything I could.
Dot, dot, dot.
Everything!
Jesus Christ.
Fuck you.
Yay!
What?!
I need milk after that.
By the way, I meant it because...
I meant it in a way...
I have like...
I don't want to boil water at the moment.
I don't...
I don't have...
Sorry, I just realized.
I don't want to boil water right now.
Because I don't have...
I don't drink tap water.
And the only thing I have in my fridge is milk.
It's milk or I boil water.
And I don't want to...
I don't want to wait for my water.
I
don't want to wait for my water to cool down.
Okay?
I'm thirsty.
I'm dehydrated.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Alright, Soren.
Because I don't drink tap water.
I have to boil it.
Like, tap water itself.
Yeah, he's pretty fucking stupid.
I just never bought a water filtration system.
That's already something I buy next.
Wait, why?
Being an adult is very hard.
Okay.
Hey, Ruben.
You...
Yipee?
Okay.
Wait, boiling water doesn't make the water better?
Wait, what?
Oh, it does make it better.
Okay, I'm just getting one guide.
Damn, thank God.
Okay, we need to find a lever.
It has to be in the chest.
Oh, I have to craft a lever.
Okay, I was like, there's no way.
There's no fucking way.
Okay, I should be able to...
make a lever, right?
Okay.
Stick.
I don't
know.
I'm trying.
It's like that XQC meme where I just do this and then be like...
I did it.
Why did he give me four sticks?
Oh my God.
I guess it's because in real Minecraft, it gives you four sticks.
But still, it just made me more confused.
First try.
We did it.
It was so hard, guys.
I had so many options.
More like, why wouldn't you?
It's because he could.
He had just too much free time in his hands.
Oh no, not a tripwire.
Oh.
Just pull the lever again.
Wait, break the lever and then put it...
put it closer to the wall.
Me building a secret passage in my solo world.
Can't they just break the wall?
We were able to break stone with like, two hits.
Wait, what?
Did he like, fucking...
Did he like, rob the order?
Wait, that's the egg, right?
Yeah, that's the ender egg.
Did I fucking release the dragon?
Pressure plate.
Yoink.
Yeah, but why does he keep all of them?
Yeah,
that is a pressure plate, right?
Oh, we just take it all.
Yoink.
Okay, and then the egg.
Oh.
Mine.
Yoink.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Why does he have the treasures?
Oh.
Oh, something happened.
They'd fuck him over somehow.
Somehow.
I don't think they actually let him.
That's a pretty suspicious answer right there.
Uh-oh.
Wait, is it?
Okay, wait.
Okay, no, I can't do anything.
Oh, there's more!
Okay.
There's more.
I didn't see this.
You can only get these underwater, right?
Yoink.
Okay.
That's all of it?
What do I have to do here?
I took all of it.
Can I talk to the doors?
Oh, okay, now I can talk to the doors.
Okay.
It's locked.
Not- Oh, there's another one!
Oh.
Oh, there's an order to everything.
Oh!
Oh, that's- This is easy.
This is so easy.
Okay, I figured it out.
Watch this, guys.
Bad.
Yeah, see, guys?
Oh.
Um.
Excuse me, wait.
Okay, I know what- Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
And then- And then it's the block of ice.
And then- Okay, wait.
What was the gas here?
Oh!
Whoops.
Whoops, I forgot.
Okay.
The gas tears.
I forgot about the gas tears.
Okay.
Look at that.
I listen- I'm a good listener, guys.
I listen.
And I listen very well.
Guys, I was a very good listener.
Yeah, who the fuck goes to the Nether first, exactly?
What the fuck?
What's going on?
Hm.
Yeah, where's- Yeah, where's Ivor's pillar?
Ivor's pillar.
Okay.
Whoa!
Okay, I don't think Ivor did all of that.
I don't think Ivor did all of that, guys.
That seems very-
I'm sorry, I didn't think Soren did all that.
Soren does not seem like a guy that- I don't know.
He doesn't-
Soren...
Why he just pokes?
Yeah.
Hm.
A bit.
Yeah.
You did all of that?
Hm.
I smell bullshit.
I don't know.
Hm.
Okay, no.
I didn't want to push.
Wait, I want to- Unpush.
Unpush the button!
Unpush it!
Wait, I don't want to skip that.
I get the story.
No!
Okay.
Okay, I fucked it up.
I fucked it up, guys.
Yeah, where is Ivor's contribution?
I feel like- Okay, how do I reset it?
I fucked it up.
Okay, I guess I have to press it all to reset it.
Because I messed it up.
Okay, I- Ooh, these controls.
Ooh.
I'm just gonna press it all.
Just so I can reset it.
Alright, so...
First was the bow.
The bow.
Then...
No, I pressed this button accidentally!
TNT.
Then he wrote the thing.
Then...
The cannon.
And then...
And then the sword.
There we go.
Well, it has to be this lever, but how do we get there?
I know, right?
There's another door.
Where is this other door?
Oh, wait, it's over here.
Okay, I was like, where did I open that?
Hello, Reuben.
Yeah, Reuben.
God damn it, Reuben.
What am I gonna do with you?
Wait.
Oh my God, I was like, where am I?
I'm like, where am I?
How do we get up there?
No!
Please.
I don't wanna hear it!
Soren, stop!
Okay.
Please.
Two sec...
In like, two sentences.
But how do we get up there?
Is there a way to get up?
What?
How do I get up?
The door is here.
It's right here, but I can't...
Guys, the door is right there.
Oh, wait.
Oh, what?
I didn't see this.
I thought it was decoration.
Oh, it is decoration.
It is!
Oh, there you go.
The assist.
It was decoration.
What do we enchant, though?
Yeah, what?
How is he at four?
Where?
Wait...
Soren...
The Ender Dragon was never dead.
Aww...
Wait, but how do we get the egg?
What?
I want the truth and nothing but the truth!
Wait, how do we get the...
They cheat with the command block!
Slash give Ender Dragon.
They just slash delete Ender Dragon.
Guys, is it obvious that I might not know how to use command blocks?
Is it sort of obvious?
Slash kill.
Slash despawn Ender Dragon.
They slash kill!
Oh my god, what?
They slash killed the Ender Dragon!
Bullshit!
Oh my god, they did slash creative mode!
They did slash game mode creative!
They made themselves admins!
They are frauds!
Slash despawn Ender Dragon!
He did slash!
Oh my god, I said it as a joke!
He did slash despawn Ender Dragon!
You're a cheat!
Oh my god, his order of the frauds!
What do you mean Soren?
He was there too!
What?
Wait, is that why he left the order?
Oh, that's true.
Ivor didn't do anything wrong!
Thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, validation for Koon right there!
He always believed in Rasputin Corps!
You're a mad man!
What?
I almost forgot for a moment.
We have to destroy it!
That's why Magnus wanted to feel like a real hero.
Okay, so how do I use the book?
My god, Ivor!
Koon, thank you for the superchat!
Thank you, thank you!
I said there's a trick to use slash despawn Ender Dragon and they actually did that!
Okay, what does he have in his chest?
Oh shit, nice!
I got diamonds!
Wait, anything?
Anything?
Okay, how do I do this?
Guys, I can mine!
It's Minecraft, guys!
Oh my god, I can do...
Oh my god, I can enchant it with Fortune 3!
Okay.
My god.
It's time to mine!
It's mine time!
It's Minecraft time!
What the mines of Wither?
It's made of blocks, it makes sense!
Wait, okay, I'm keeping... Guys, I have to...
I have to keep with Magnus' armor, guys.
I'll keep Magnus' armor.
Or he would have died for fucking nothing.
Yeah, I was gonna say, he literally dies for nothing if I don't.
But he's a fraud!
It's the only time he can redeem himself.
I like my fucking pickaxe!
It's time to mine!
I'm ready!
My weapon!
Oh my god, look at the Endermen!
Jesus Christ.
What?
Oh, he's alive!
Where's the amulet?
Yeah.
Why are they angry?
God!
They're just sure like that.
We fight till the death!
That's right!
We all die tonight!
Either or!
Oh my gosh, it's my blue-eyed horse.
It reminds me of him.
Okay, how do I make the Endermen hangy?
I'm ready!
Sorin, what do your wives say?
Sorin, I said to her at death, Sorin!
Sorin!
What?
Oh, fucking coward!
You coward!
I thought we were best friends!
Oh, he cares, guys.
He would actually care, guys.
It is doomed.
He actually cares.
Oh, when the thing's on him, he gets angry.
That's right.
I stare!
Get mad!
Break my down!
Jesus Christ, I'm so...
What the fuck?
I wish you could actually do that in Minecraft.
Slap a block out of an Enderman's head.
That's right!
Get mad!
Mask up, Jesse!
Yes, they're falling for it.
What happens if I...
Oh, I just...
I just walked away.
I was like, what happens if I don't do it?
Okay.
One of them.
What?
Oh, okay, that helped.
That worked.
Okay, so I have to do as many as I can.
Or it won't work.
Why don't I just push them?
What the fuck is that pig gonna do?
Yeah, that's right, nerd!
What the fuck?
Give me a locker.
I'm ready to put them in a locker.
Okay,
this is gonna take a while.
There's a lot of Endermen.
Like, I'm doing it two by... like, two by two.
And, like, apparently I need hundreds of Endermen.
I know, like, why is nobody helping me?
I'm just leading them.
Oh, is it crafting time?
Right?
Rockin' minecart!
Yeah!
We're at war!
We're gonna MacGyver it, yeah.
Yeah.
She'll be okay, guys.
She's done it before.
Wait, guys, I don't know how to craft this.
Guys, wait.
What if we all fly away?
I'm so tempted to just have...
Lucas!
Wait, how come they're okay?
Why don't they look as fucked up as her?
Look at that.
See, guys, I didn't fuck it up.
I didn't fuck it up, guys.
He still thinks we're friends.
Give us a sec.
We're making the rockin' minecart.
Sounded the coolest.
It's not doomed, guys!
Wait, Ruby, what are you doing here?
Ruben, you're fucking useless in here!
What the fuck?
Is this a wither disease?
Oh, they are!
Wait, they're the wither citizens.
Is this what they're gonna turn into?
Wait, we're inside.
Aren't we gonna turn into wither guys?
Oh my god, that's the butcher!
Ruben!
You fucker!
Come back!
Don't be useless!
Oh no.
Oh, Ruben, now you come back after I fucking fell.
There it is.
Slash despawn wither.
It's time to mine the command block, guys.
Guys, the pickaxe is actually the perfect weapon.
It's time to mine the command block.
There it is.
I actually chose the right weapon.
The right tool for the job.
That's right, here I go.
Look at that.
With my efficiency 5, fortune 3.
What the fuck is he trying to do?
Oh my god, I mined a tentacle.
You gotta hold down the button.
Oh my god, I almost... Okay, I gotta hold down.
Don't worry, I got you.
I feel like... Oh shit.
I was gonna say, I feel like I'll instant die if I fuck it up one time.
Oh shit, I almost pressed Q.
That didn't count, guys.
That didn't count.
I was like, hmm, if I press one wrong button, do I just die?
Now we know, now we know.
Now we know, guys.
It was educational.
I was trying to figure it out.
That's right, one more hit.
Just needs one more.
How the fuck did I get up there?
What?
Oh my god.
Ruben's just like, okay.
Hop, hop, hop, hop, hop, hop, hop.
I'm here now.
Why did it not bring any blocks with me?
I could've just built up.
Oh no.
Why did I not bring any- Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, he like, inverted his head.
Wait, that's fucked.
Ruben, why can't you listen?
Ruben, I had one simple instruction for you.
Wait, I could just mine it right now.
Wait, you're right, I could just mine a block right now.
And then build up.
Stay out of sight, Ruben!
But you won't listen.
Oh!
Oh, that's smart.
How did I not get the Wither Sickness, though?
Yoink.
Time for the final- Oh!
Ruben!
Bring... bring... pickaxe... to daddy!
That's it, that's it.
That's right, that's right.
Come on, Ruben, I believe in you.
To me!
Don't- To me!
Ruben!
Yes, that's right!
I'll catch you!
Ruben, no!
Okay, okay.
Okay, I'll catch him.
Ruben, I'll catch you for sure!
No, no, no, no, no!
I just - I just wanted to see!
I just- I just wanted to see!
I have one redo!
And my intrusive thoughts won, okay, guys?
I couldn't help it!
The intrusive thoughts won!
I'm so sorry.
Look, it was all just- See, I caught him.
I did- I would never do that to you, Ruben.
Oh my god, Ruben!
Oh my god, he has his legs!
Quick!
Ruben!
Wait, what now?
I didn't know he'd actually fall!
He falls anyway!
What now?
I didn't know right after!
Oh, it's okay, there's water.
He definitely landed in the water, right, guys?
Guys, where's Ruben?
It was the funny prank!
It was a dream!
I caught him!
Guys, I caught him!
I caught him, though!
The only pilot that was alive!
Ruben, I caught you!
Remember, Ruben?
I caught you, Ruben!
Ruben!
Ruben, are you okay?
Guys, do you think he's okay?
Do you think he's okay?
Are you okay?
Get off, Ruben!
Ruben, I need you!
It was a joke!
It was a prank, Ruben!
I'm so sorry!
It was a prank!
I caught you!
Ruben, remember?
Oh
my god!
I'm so sorry!
Oh my god!
Ruben, will you remember?
It was just a joke!
I caught you, Ruben!
I caught you!
I didn't think he'd fall!
I didn't think... I didn't realize that's how he dies!
One week later...
Oh my god!
What did I do with the pork?
What did I do with it?
The butcher was invited to his funeral?
That's fucked.
Why is he still wearing the fishbowl?
Who
invited the fucking butcher?
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Oh, that was a bad time.
He microwaved hot dogs.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Wait, he lives?
They deserve... No, they deserve to tell them the truth.
We didn't give Magnus a memorial!
Wait, you're right!
Expose yourself now.
That pig died for this.
He poor will remember that.
Me!
I can't believe Magnus did not get a funeral.
I had Reuben!
Fuck you guys.
I had Reuben.
Everyone loves pigs.
True.
The power of pigs.
They were there, I guess.
The others were there.
I didn't think you would fall right after!
Boomtown!
That's my highlight.
Yeah,
me!
That's me!
You know what really matters?
Dot dot dot.
I did it!
What am I doing in the Netherstar?
Jesse, that's me.
Thank god I played as the guy from Patton Oswalt.
My god, it's beautiful.
Jesse!
Oh, we're the new order?
Oh my god, I did it, guys.
Alright, so by the law of the order, the stone broke.
And one of us will die in the end.
Why is that voice actor so familiar?
I did it!
Yeah!
Is that Zack Brannigan?
Oh my god, it's Futurama!
That's why!
He sounds...
It's Zack Brannigan!
I was being narrated by fucking Zack Brannigan!
I was like, why do I feel like I've heard this voice before?
Yes, Billy West!
He's the guy who was Fry, the professor, Zack Brannigan, and he does a lot of other ones.
But these are the ones I remember off the top of my head.
Oh my god.
That was fun.
That was pretty fun, guys.
I can't believe... How long were we streaming for?
Holy shit.
We went all the way from episode 1 to 4.
That was crazy.
I can't believe we made it.
We did it all the way to the end.
But we're not gonna do the DLC.
We did 6 hours, finished the main story arc.
I had a great... I think my favorite episode has to be episode 4.
Episode 4 was definitely my favorite out of the 4 episodes.
The 4th episode was my favorite for sure.
I think I liked the 4th episode the most out of all the episodes.
I think the... which one was it?
The one where I did not realize that he dies right after I catch him.
So yeah, when I... I didn't realize it was just that part.
I couldn't help it.
My intrusive thoughts just won that day.
Like, he was gonna fall anyway.
Like, what the fuck?
And I think when Soren did the slash and he spawned Ender Dragon, it was pretty funny.
I did not expect that to actually happen.
I thought it was like a joke, but he actually slash despawned him.
But I enjoyed it a lot.
I definitely enjoyed playing the Minecraft Story Telltale game, Story Mode.
Zekra, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Pour one out for Ruben.
We lost a good one.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching the entire stream.
I mean, for those who stuck it up from the very beginning, from when it started to now, like, congratulations to you guys, because it's also really, really, like, for some of you guys, especially the East Coast viewers.
But yeah, thank you all for sticking it out for six plus hours today.
Dan, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, it was a wild ride.
I guess we'll never know what the handshake is like, because I fucked up.
I legitimately didn't even see... I didn't even see the QuickTime event.
It happened so fast, it didn't show up.
Like, my eyes didn't... I was not, like, comprehending that there was a QuickTime event there.
I was just like, that's it.
But thank you everybody for watching.
Thank you for all the raids.
Thank you for all the superchats and everything.
I guess, like, before I go, I usually would do an after stream chat, but...
But I did stream for six plus hours, so I'm going to rest now.
Anyway, guys, for those who don't know, my YouTube plush has one week left.
So please, if you want to get any of my plushies from YouTubes, they end in a week.
And it's the last... After their preorder is done, you won't be able to get them anymore.
So if you really, really want these plushies, this is, like, the perfect time to get them.
Or they'll be gone forever, or you have to find them at really, really expensive prices on eBay or something.
I don't know.
Or maybe just wait until I fall off, and then maybe it'll be cheaper.
Anyway, guys, thank you all for watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
Thank you everybody for watching.
Thank you all for always supporting me.
I'm gonna head off now.
See you everybody.
Bye bye!